okay for the committee because we're
about ready to go ahead here
for the committee i have an announcement
um
the schedule for getting bills out of
committee has been moved
and the first session day will be on
the date that all bills had to be
reported out early bills was the 17th
because now with that session days on
the 15th the date for us to get early
bills out is the
um 10th
at noon
so yeah that's oh great is right we
we've heard most of our early bills we
have 15 early bills
and i believe the schedule we have set
up we can get that we have just about a
full day and a half to take care of
executing 15 bills that should not be an
issue
if
those that are looking to do amendments
can get those amendments done prior to
that particular day
i understand there's times when we're in
session or in an executive session
and we all concur we need an amendment
to this because it's basically it's got
some good stuff in it
that we can take care of but if you have
something that you're working on try and
get it going right now i had a chat with
anthony this morning and he encouraged
us to try and get things done as quickly
as possible in terms of amending
language
yes we do um
of course you note that executive
sessions may follow any on any bill any
day
uh but on the if you look at january the
25th
that is a tuesday
we have one bill at the top of the
schedule there
1660 which is an early bill
but then we have following executive
session on pending legislation maybe
held throughout the day we will be going
into executive session on on the 25th
there's absolutely no question we will
be doing that
we got to
um on the 25th of january then there is
another one a date that i have i don't
believe it's in this calendar
[Music]
let's see if i've got that too
which i do yes okay
uh
yes on the ninth
we have that day set aside for exacting
all day all day on the 9th of february
and i had the 10th originally set for
exacting all day but now we've been told
we have half a day
so at this point in time
um
we we have those days set aside although
we have some other days where we're
hearing only uh like five bills on
february the 8th
so that gives us opportunity to have
exec sessions there as we get closer to
those dates i will let you know
yes
yeah
i think if you talk to dave he can tell
you where to find that
there's a search there where you can
pick all that up
yep
okay with that i'd like to go ahead with
our first hearing for today
that's uh hb 1632 relative civil rights
education and public elementary and
secondary schools
welcome representative
thank you uh
touching right yeah thank you mr chair
appreciate it
um
my name is jordan ellery hillsborough 37
hudson and pelham
and i'm here to introduce the uh the
bill referenced 1632 fn although the fn
is a minuscule amount of 27 000
28 000 something like that
at any rate i can
i'm happy to to join with you today and
what i hope is the beginning of a new
approach to teaching race relations in
my background
as some of you may know comes from
northern indiana
large amish population in the uh town
where i was raised and my grandparents
lived just up the street as it were as
say up here
in elkhart
my other grandparents my maternal
grandparents lived in harlan kentucky
if you look up harlan kentucky you'll
see the uh appalachian
bloody harlan
and there's a reason for that both the
cold wars and the unions
and uh there were some other incidents
that took place
that's where i first became as a young
child in the 60s
50s and 60s
i hate to say 50s
being related to
race relations it was kind of
interesting to ask my father why there
were two drinking fountains at the
county courthouse i had no idea why
and didn't
understand it
that experience
carried me forward
this last summer i ran into a gentleman
by the name of dr matthew daniels who
talked about this particular program
this program has already been adopted in
several states and it's being considered
in another
for this term
uh texas georgia the dakotas
uh colorado
right off the top of my head
it's interesting that the dakotas are
thinking of it because two of my
classmates who are twins
you one was in north dakota and one was
in south dakota have the same office
that we hold as state representatives
although they get paid more
or got paid more than they've retired
now
one of the things that
stuck with me from my childhood was the
fact that
dr king was able to take
a potentially violent situation
i can potentially
confrontational situation
and reduce it down to what i was being
taught
in my school at the time
his
i have a dream speech and capture
encapsulates that
very well when he speaks about the fact
that we need that he has a dream someday
that his children will be judged by the
quality of their character
not by the color of their skin
and we need to get back to that i think
nationwide to talk about
who the person is
not whether they're
black green brown orange
whatever
that which is superficial
dr
daniels has worked with ambassador young
and
several other
leaders in the historical black colleges
and university community to develop this
program for high school students
and it can be adopted for
kindergarten right on through
it was originally
sponsored by i have a handout there
there from
mcgraw-hill
but now two other
primary school
publishers have
joined
on to this program as well to have their
own uh
types of these
now i don't think i need to go through
the credentials of
uh ambassador young a pretty courageous
uh man and his youth and he's now 93 and
he's still fighting which is something i
think
several of us can aspire to well let me
talk about dr daniels for a half a
second he's got his uh
jd he's got a phd he grew up in spanish
harlem
he received full scholarship
to dartmouth college so it's appropriate
that he wants to try and get
this program back
into new hampshire to use this program
now
if you take a look at your global
perspective that
was handed out it's the paperclip copy
you have a background of the the entire
program and how it is going to operate
and what the uh guides are there
i don't
pretend to be an expert in education
but i do know
a good program when i see it the people
talk about
dr king
and his ideals and his mission
i want
a program like that
to be taught to my grandchildren and
great-grandchildren
um yeah
i don't think that's going to happen for
a while but anyway when it does i hope
that they have
that kind of education to teach
people
to appreciate one another
and not to classify them by
political party or skin color or
hair color although there are some good
this is why this bill has been
introduced
now it's particularly a point
and
important
that we consider
what
dr young had dr young dr king had to say
about this here in new hampshire
from his uh i have a dream speech he
says
let us not seek to satisfy our thirst
for freedom by drinking from the cup of
bitterness or hatred
we must ever conduct our struggle on the
high plain of dignity and discipline
he goes on further
to remind us
that freedom
entails respect for one another
and then he employs us to let freedom
ring
from the prodigious hilltops of new
hampshire
so i think
this type of legislation
here in new hampshire is imminently
appropriate
i know that dr
daniels will be providing you with some
additional information i've already sent
you some information
via email including links to different
programs and different videos including
a video from dr
our ambassador young
but i would be willing to answer any
questions that anyone may have about
this particular program
thank you very much representative are
there questions from the committee yes
thank you mr chair and um thank you rep
ulri for bringing this forward um this
is a very timely and needed program i
was wondering if you've looked at any
other programs and
why you went with this one
actually i've seen several other
programs from some of the educational
conferences that i've attended over the
last several years
this one stood out though because it
took
uh something that seems to have been
lost in the country
that is the concept of uh
acceptance
of an individual regardless of
what they happen to be there are some
programs out there that uh
would
classify individuals because of who or
what or
they are rather than
beginning from the premise that we're
all equal
i'm kind of reminded of the uh
song i learned as a
as a child i was doing this with my wife
in the car the other day jesus loves all
the children better than yellow black
and white they are all equal in his
sight
thank you for the question thank you
further questions
not yes representative moffett thank you
mr thank you for your uh your measure
and i applied the intent um yesterday we
heard in this committee room
proposals measures bills to uh mandate
everything from a philosophy course to a
labor course and more
so my question hopefully follow up my
question is do you envision this measure
as being implemented as a standalone
course or
embedded in an existing course
yes
either or so
yes and the the way that this course is
designed it could also be a monitored uh
distance learning course
which is
one of the programs that dr daniels is
involved in
in a follow-up mr chair yes you may
thank you
um
mathematics is relatively finite in
terms of the body of knowledge that is
uh
is taught
um having been in this business uh
history or social studies is not
when people taught history in the in the
70s
there was so much this 50 there's a half
century more history now for students to
be to learn
in some fashion which is a challenge so
what would you say to somebody from this
would presumably be part of a social
studies uh department thing what would
you say to someone who would just
respond that this is a good idea but
they just are overwhelmed and they don't
know how they can integrate it into what
they're already trying to do
a good choice of words there integrate
um
the
there are certain elements
that transcend time
and this
concept of acceptance of an individual
of treating an individual as an
individual transcends
the limits of time
whether it's
17 20
18 20 19 20 or 20 20.
then you're achieving
a goal and that's what this course tries
to do is try to instill in the student
the concept within their own mind of of
appreciation as they learn
all the other programs
this will
fit into it
you're right about 50 years of history
some of it which i wish we didn't have
to live but was there
thank you
thank you further representative ellison
uh there's probably a point of
information i think uh
i'm on the commission
holocaust commission it's the commission
on the holocaust and genocide studies
and i serve along with dan wolf who was
on this committee
and that
that's a law that when the commission
was set up and is now
getting to the point where the final
hearing on the rules will take place
next month
at the state board of education and then
move to jail car
everything that's in this bill is
included in that that particular piece
of legislation uh and there are some
mandates in there in terms of when
things would be taught how they would be
taught uh it's very specific so i'm just
simply adding that as
sort of additional information to
this piece of him for this piece of
legislation
thank you very much
yes representative tanner
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question i
was wondering if you could explain
what how you think
this particular topic is being taught in
high schools in new hampshire right now
and um how this one this particular
curriculum because it is a curriculum
how it um
differs from
uh divisive concepts or how it how
it eludes the
statute that we now have that we cannot
teach divisive concepts
thank you
i don't understand your question
so my fir it's a two-part question
question part number one is how do you
think or what do you think
new hampshire schools are doing
currently
teaching this particular subject
and second of all
because there was this outcry that you
know new hampshire schools were teaching
crt
which they're not but they were accused
of that we had the divisive concept
statute
come through
uh the legislature and so what i'm
asking in the second part is
compared to what you think we're
teaching in schools today
how is this different and how does it
not
fall under divisive concepts thank you
want to answer your uh your
second question first
it has nothing to do with divisive
concepts it's not teaching a divisive
concept
on the
on the other hand what his teaching is
uh as was said by representative moffat
more of an integrated
um point of view of accepting each
individual for themselves
regardless of anything that may separate
heritage or ethnic background or
anything else rather than
allow the separation factors to come in
you talk about teaching each individual
as an individual
not as
a
chartreuse four-legged
or whatever into per uh thing you teach
them as a human being
which unfortunately you know uh you you
take a look back at world war one and uh
the propaganda of uh wilson at the time
was the hun
well
you know those guys didn't want to be in
in the trenches any more than the french
or the british didn't wanted to be in
the trenches
ah
you have to then 1914 christmas kind of
taught that but you need to
that's why
there's no correlation so you can't
answer your second part of the question
and the first part of the question was
what do i think is being taught in in
schools right now
not enough about how to treat each other
yes we need to we have a number of cards
here also so we need to
um
well if you're afraid to teach
sergeant of truth
i'm
sorry for you
because that's not divisive
represent representative cornell
thank you thank you for taking my
question i just it's just a question of
are you proposing this particular
curriculum or or just that these kind of
materials get covered in a in a class or
or um
dr d
is it daniel's dr dana's particular
course material
um the particular course material is the
one that has been presented to us
several other states and they picked
that up but uh simon and schuster who
have also joined along with harper
collins
in uh picking up the same thing so
they're teaching essentially the same or
the printing essentially the same course
material by the the three
educational uh publishers
follow-up yes
so you don't care if it's this
particular curriculum as long as these
materials get covered in school that's
correct thank you thank you
president
thank you very much mr chair thank you
very much for taking my question
representative would would it be your
intention for this um
um
this uh proposed um legislation to also
uh several non-public schools are
already teaching this particular type of
curriculum of their own uh degree but
any uh since we don't have any control
over other than broadly through the uh
department of education regarding the
curriculum that the non-public schools
have the public schools which includes
charter schools
this would be included in their
curriculum
follow up on that yes
first of all charter charter public
schools uh would need to be called out
specifically in the statute uh in order
for them to for that to apply
um uh would would it also be your
intention though for um
for this um this policy to apply to
non-public schools that are under
yes
that would include pinkerton i believe
is one of the such school and
technically alvirne from the district in
which i'm involved in
is uh
uh i mean the school itself is a trust
private academy uh atkinson academy is
another one of those little weird
leftovers from the 18th century 19th
century brother so yes
great thank you
are there any further questions from the
committee not seeing hands thank you
like to call forward uh
megan tuttle
thank you chairman lad members of the
committee i'll keep this short interest
of time i do have some written testimony
that i will
pass out in a moment for the record my
name is megan tuttle president for nea
new hampshire representing more than 17
000 educators across the state of new
hampshire
we are here today in opposition to house
basically there's there's two points
i'll make here um because i know there's
a lot of other testimony the first one
as representative tanner um already
alluded to there is fear among educators
in the state today there's a lot of fear
i hear from them they're in the
classroom they're they're fearful of
what they can and can't say in the
classroom anymore because of the banned
concepts um
and i think this
is going to add to that as
representative tanner said this is true
this is what's happening the educators
are letting me know that this is
happening in the schools today the other
piece of this is partially what
representative elliott had mentioned and
alluded to earlier that
in 2020 the governor signed into law the
commission pursuant to rsa 133 e2f
which made the recommendations to the
state board of education adopting rules
around holocaust and genocide education
i believe um
it's been the hearing has been delayed a
few times i was at the state board of
education meeting last week and it was
delayed again but that's work that's
been going on that's included in this
already so this is really duplicate of
what's already happening and will be
happening
in there
there's also rsa 189 11
ij referenced in the bill it already
states new hampshire government civics
courses include instruction and how
intolerance bigotry anti-semitism
national ethnic racial or religious
hatred and discrimination have evolved
in the past and can evolved into
genocide and mass violence such as the
holocaust and how to prevent the
evolution of such practices um basically
this is this is already in statute it's
already in rules that are already
in place and so
i'll leave it at that for now thank you
thank you very much uh megan i have a
question for you it should be a quick
one
i'm sure that you have the opportunity
to go around to all the schools within
the state and observe in classrooms
what's going on
hopefully
is it your perception or observation
that
issues such as dealing with the wagers
in northwestern china and their
enslavement in various labor camps etc
uh issues dealing with the holocaust
issues dealing with this topic that we
passed within the genocide that
represented
ellison referred to are being taught in
the schools right now
thank you for the question um i have not
been to every class obviously in the
state and um the pandemic is limited
when i'm able to actually go into the
classroom so my interaction has been
limited to speaking with educators
across the state but i can say that i do
believe those are being taught in new
hampshire i can't say for sure in every
class but i'm sure in some they are
thank you very much further questions
from the committee
not singing hands thank you very much
ah now it's done thank you uh good
morning thank you for the chance to
address you this morning my name is
deborah howes and i'm the president of
aft
new hampshire
uh the other teachers union in the state
we represent about 3 500 teachers para
educators
school support staff public service
employees and
higher ed staff across the state
and i'm here this morning to talk about
this bill
not because we oppose teaching on the
civil rights era we actually you know
thoroughly encourage that and notice the
part of any good
course in american history but we
are concerned that by passing a specific
law
requiring
teaching as described in this bill
it would take it out its full sweep of
a course of american history aft firmly
believes in providing students with a
robust engaging factual u.s history
education so that they can understand
how our nation was formed and the
changes has undergone through the years
up to including the present time
this proposal of study is laudable as it
is
needs a lot of background knowledge for
students to fully grasp the significance
of the civil rights era to our nation
for example students must first
comprehend the evils of the
transatlantic slave trade and slavery as
it existed in the united states
students need to see how the tactics of
the abolitionist suffragist and labor
movement as well as the strength of
community within black churches helped
shape the individuals and organizations
that made up the civil rights movement
students need to understand that free
black men gained the right to vote be
educated and own property during
reconstruction the 1870s then those
rights were taken away or severely
curtailed through poll taxes literacy
tests segregation laws and peonage
starting in the 1890s
students need to understand the
experience of segregation the jim crow
era
vigilante action of lynchings and
violent outbreaks in places such as
wilmington north carolina in 1898 elaine
arkansas in 1919 and tulsa oklahoma in
1921.
these are some of the background that
students need to put the civil rights
era in context in united states history
it is necessary so they can understand
what it was that the individuals and
organizations of the civil rights
movement were seeking to overcome
and comprehend their successes and their
failures and realize what yet remains
undone
as part of a robust well-rounded
curriculum of u.s history students would
encounter these concepts before they
study the civil rights era if a
stand-alone law required teaching of
civil rights era past
some of those building blocks might be
shortchanged in the rush to get to this
unit
so
as described in this bill
if this were were
put into law it might
unbalance some of the social studies
courses uh in american history as
teachers try and get to this which is
man did um
and rush past other things
as someone alluded to earlier there's 50
more years of history than there were
when some of us took it
and if you're hurrying to get to this
you might miss some of those other
important building blocks
the appropriate place for this proposal
is at the new hampshire department of
education through inclusion in our
revised state standards or frameworks
for social studies
that way we can be sure that the civil
rights era is taught in a way that
respects the need for all the necessary
prerequisite learning
for a full and robust understanding of
those ideas
we can be sure that the intended
enduring understanding of this unit that
hatred based on immutable
characteristics produces profound
injustice and should always be worked
against
we want to make sure that idea does not
get diluted because students are
unprepared
with the background knowledge that they
need
the new hampshire state framework on
social studies was last updated in 2006
and is supposed to be updated every 10
years it's overdue but it's in process
right now
aft new hampshire urges you to vote itl
on this bill and work with the new
hampshire department of ed to get this
unit included in a cohesive framework
that ties together all the necessary
elements of a robust
robust
social studies education
so that will work in the best interest
of students
i want to thank you
for um letting me present the concerns
of my members thank you very much for
your testimony are there any questions
yes representative luno
thank you very much mr chair thank you
very much miss howe for uh for joining
us this morning and for um for providing
i think some very compelling uh
testimony um
would would you
see um uh see any advantage i guess
to uh to possibly um
you know codifying something maybe as an
amendment to uh to this
to this proposed language
that would um
do what you suggested at the that you
suggested just a minute ago that would
um uh have the um
you know
provide i guess some some
uh
effort to work with the department of
education you know i think you you use
cohesive framework during the revised
during the process that they they have
right now to um to revise the
yes if that were
the focus of the bill to get this into
the social studies standards this is an
appropriate thing to to be looking at it
belongs in social studies but not in a
vacuum okay it has to be part of
the sequence of
events you can't look at you know you
can't look at the facts without the
causes
right right um thank you thank you very
much
thank you very much are there further
questions for
uh
the testimony from the aft
nazi thank you very much
well i i think that
not from where you are right now if you
wanted to speak and support against
or against this particular bill you
would have to fill out a pink card as
the others have done as well
you would have to fill out a pink card
you will have the opportunity to speak
about that of course for an executive
session as well
and but while you're making your mind up
we're going to go out with the next
yeah
you would need to fill one of these out
um the next person to speak is
anna
helena ellen i is
she here
welcome
uh excuse me yes if you press the the
mic we can hear you okay
can you hear me now oh yes yes all right
so uh my name is
and i am with rights and democracy new
hampshire i am also an immigrant and i
consider myself a global citizen of the
world
so happy to be here today first of all
i'd like to start off by saying i love
the idea of learning about what's going
on in other countries i think that many
people in the united states are not in
touch as a nation with other countries
their trials and tribulations their
contributions including the immense
resources we all depend on from them
instead it's being used
this noble idea of learning about others
and turns it on its head
by using others faults to make our
faults look less bad instead of learning
about other nations including the great
cultural practices that incredibly
support people in their weakest moments
or what great inventions or geniuses
there are out there as well as the bad
which i'm not promoting we leave out
in fact
discriminatory injustice topics from
other nations are being taught just not
intentionally being forced into a unit
to be taught about american civil rights
i want us to think about why we would do
such a thing
why are we so seeking to show the faults
of others when learning about our own
faults in the history of the united
states
why do we have a need to maintain this
image of a perfect america
i think it's because we somehow are
convinced ourselves that if there were
serious wrongs and if there are serious
wrongs that people will not be able to
love america or worse that they might
hate it
i challenge us to rethink this reasoning
and to understand
by teaching real history without tactics
to downplay the reality of our mistakes
allows students to see a world where
mistakes do happen and can be fixed
we cannot get to amer a more fairer
world without understanding history and
how we got to where we are today
h hb 1632 will absolve ourselves of
having to reckon with our own past by
comparing the united states human rights
atrocities to the human rights horrors
that have happened in other countries
with different governments and different
time periods one has nothing to do with
the other
because of all these reasons i asked the
committee to strongly oppose hb
thank you
thank you for your testimony see i have
to push the button too
uh are there any questions from the
committee
not seeing any hands thank you very much
for coming today thank you you're
welcome
i have another card here from frank
frank i
you're you know i'm sorry my eyes are
either not good or my penmanships uh
anyways frank is from the aclu of new
hampshire welcome frank can you
apologize mr chairman your last name
please it's uh connect k-n-a
okay yeah sorry my i think it's my
handwriting that is it looks like a w so
thank you very much frank devlin thank
uh thank you mr chairman members of the
committee for the opportunity to testify
today uh my name is frank knack and
policy director
with the aclu of new hampshire and we
are here in opposition uh to this
legislation
uh you know many many of the important
points that i wanted to raise have
already been raised so i don't want to
um repeat repeat what's already been
said uh very well
i think just to kind of sum this up
there's two things that we are concerned
about with this bill that i think
regardless of the intent how it could be
actualized or concerning one is as has
been mentioned it downplays our unique
history i think it was well covered the
the things the context that's necessary
to understand how we got to the civil
rights movement in the 50s and 60s
from you know slavery to convict leasing
tulsa
racial terror etc
i think what hadn't been noted too is
this notion that
everything has been fined since 68 which
this legislation if implemented could
could lead towards and i think that
would undermine you know at the most
foundational level the war on drugs you
have john ehrlich man who was nixon's
domestic policy advisor
who oversaw the implementation of the
war on drugs on record saying the war on
drugs was to quote control the black
community and control the anti-war
movement that context is necessary and i
think it leads to where we are today
where we have a mass incarceration
crisis in this country and where black
people are disproportionately
incarcerated at all levels including
here in new hampshire
new for example in new hampshire right
now we know that black people and white
people use marijuana at roughly the same
rate yet black people are 4.1 times more
likely to be arrested for marijuana
possession than white people
how did we get here that history that
context is important i think it's also
important to recognize the extreme
racial wealth divide we have in this
country where black the average black
family has 17 000 in wealth the average
white family has a hundred and seventy
one thousand dollars in wealth a ten
times increase over the average black
family and how did we get there and it's
the laws and policies that have been in
place at our country since the beginning
that led us here from you know having
laws and policies to protected the slave
owner against the abolitionist laws and
policies that allowed for convict
leasing to go after slavery was quote
unquote abolished after the civil war
laws and policies that protected the jim
crow segregationists over the civil
rights protesters laws and policies that
continue to protect police violence over
those who are trying to stop it i think
it's important that students in our
state understand that history understand
the context and legislation like this
will bring us in the wrong direction so
thank you so much for the opportunity to
testify
thank you for being here today are there
any questions from the committee
not seeing hands thank you very much
thank you
i'm no more pink cards at this time
so with that
see what time is it
we have about three minutes before we
okay
once again for committee members if you
have a bill you have to testify in
another committee just please you know
go to that and then come back following
that
and i think we're ready to go forward at
this time with hb
1190 1190 this is relative to rule
making by the state board of education
for compliance with federal provisions
so with that uh a welcome to the
excuse me thank you mr chair and thank
you honorable committee members
uh for listening to my testimony today
uh i was uh brought the idea for this
bill from a fellow representative so i
hope i do it justice and this is my
first
uh bill my first bill that i'm
sponsoring so i'm going to channel my
inner rep litchfield and ask for
forgiveness and
as we go forward um
thank you for allowing me to present
hb11190 to you today
one of the many great discoveries i have
made as a legislator and former school
board member is how grant money works
when the money is received it's exciting
to think of the opportunities this gift
can create
as a legislator i'm also learning about
the rules and framework of that grant
money and just how much work needs to be
done before the grant is accepted here's
an example
uh on tuesday our committee held a
hearing for hb 154 f-n-l
requiring school districts to provide
breakfast for students
like the great mr frew i don't know if
he's here or not from the
superintendent's association said to be
against a bill like this would be to
disagree with puppies and apple pie or
something like that
i know as legislators we would love to
be able to to cover the cost of
breakfast for all students every day but
this but often well-intentioned money is
short-sighted while attempting to do
something positive we don't look at the
long-term impacts of a program
what if the program expands how do we
cover the cost for a successful program
in the years to come
who will oversee the program and are
there additional costs associated with
program startup
grant programs that offer full or near
full funding support at startup but in
subsequent years when the federally
mandated funded program is reduced by
half or more
local boards are left with few options
boards can either make difficult k-12
programming reductions that harm all
students or if operational reductions
are not made that way made that way
boards are forced to increase local
property taxes a nightmare for every
community
this situation is especially true with
special education costs for example in
california the annual cost of educating
a student with disabilities averages
about twenty seven thousand per student
compared with general education costs at
about ten thousand per student in recent
years the funding from federal
government is below 15 of the average
per pupil expenditure
in new hampshire state and local
appropriations have picked up that
difference along with all costs above
the 40 percent promised by the federal
government
should this measure
hb1190 pass
any mandated curriculum or program of
study by federal or state must be
accompanied with an adequate fiscal note
to
sustain local costs for implementation
imper improper funding of state mandates
in new hampshire violates our new
hampshire constitution
under part first
bill of rights article 28a
i think about these programs becoming
local taxpayer responsibilities with
only a rising tax bill to let them know
the program even exists
i think we can and should do better for
our constituents let's hold the federal
government to the state same standards
to which we hold ourselves
this measure does not oppose the federal
government but does tell the state board
that they cannot create rules where
there is a lack of federal funding
similar bills have been heard in the
education committee and this committee
has also voted down
federal
federal regulation that could not be
fully funded
so i welcome your feedback and comments
and let's
make this a bipartisan effort thank you
thank you very much representative are
there questions from the committee
representative tanner
thank you mr chair thank you and you did
a great job for the presentation so
thank you and and i fully support the
idea that
whatever
happens whatever we do
should we should take into consideration
long-term impact
how to cover costs
how it's going to be overseen and the
cost was start-up and i think we need
really
competent
and accurate fiscal notes
i'm talking
and the federal government has has left
us short several times okay
i totally agree with that
however i was wondering how you think
this applies to the state
we have a voucher program that we got
with 129 000 physical note which was now
over 68 million dollars
so that's
a big thing there was no oversight
really um
on how that money was being spent or how
it was being accounted for
um no way really
no cost for startups we heard from the
department of education yesterday that
um
you know it they need a administrator at
doe because they didn't realize how much
it was going to cost for the startup
so
i guess what i would like to see and
whether you would be amenable to it or
not
that
we actually outline
those statements that you made
and make it available or applicable to
both federal and our state government
would you would you agree that
perhaps that would be a good amendment
for this bill
um i i would be open to a discussion
about that for sure
not seeing any thank you very much
thank you everyone
okay i do not on that one have any other
pink cards
so with that we're going to close this
hearing
and you have an opportunity to
walk around stretch and
maybe get a little brunch or whatever
so the next one we have
starts up at
10 30 excuse 10 30 no wait a minute or
not
i'm looking at election loss excuse me
i've done that several times here 10 30
when the next bill starts that will be
13 11 when we start in approximately a
little over 35 minutes
35 40 minutes
okay
oh
uh
right
okay
um
good
okay
um
oh
i'm not taking the heat
can you hear me representative mullen
can you hear me
yes
um
hey
hey there's something that happened
it was the disconnect under here so i'm
going to re-tape this line after but
under the strip
yeah
okay we're going to go ahead with this
hearing saying we need to capture some
time here
uh i like to open up the hearing for hb
1311 prohibiting persons charged with or
with or convicted of a certain assault
or controlled drug
possession violations from employment in
a public school welcome representative
mullen thank you mr chair and as gilda
radner always said
it's always something
yes uh
thank you mr chair and house education
for hearing me this morning for the
record my name is sue mullen and i
represent hillsborough county district 7
the town of bedford
house bill 1311 seeks to add felony
convictions of first degree assault and
possession of a controlled drug with the
intent to sell
to the list of rsa 189 13a section 5
offenses
that prohibit employment in a school
administrative unit school district
chartered public school or public
academy
for the purpose of explanation for new
members on our committee i have
distributed electronically a list of the
current offenses that we commonly and
collectively refer to as the section
fives
and i will remind returning members that
last year at this time
we added human trafficking to that list
that change was the result of
conversation precipitated by information
shared by doe attorney diana fenton
regarding questions about why a
substantial number of people get
credentialed in new hampshire but never
actually teach here evidently the
reciprocity aspect with other states is
attractive to a lot of folks
we all agreed that we did not want folks
found guilty of human trafficking in new
hampshire schools
the conversation has continued in this
session i'm bringing forward house bill
1311 to prohibit people convicted of
first degree assault and people found
guilty of possession of a controlled
drug with the intent to distribute
from being employed in schools as well
please understand that the criminal
offenses i reference are felonies we are
not talking about a schoolyard fist
fight
if you take a look at chapter 631-1
which i distributed to you
electronically i also have hard copies
here for anybody who uh either did not
receive it or wants to reference it
later on
uh you'll see that we're talking about
purposefully causing serious bodily
injury
we're talking about purposely or
knowingly causing injury with a deadly
weapon
purposely or knowingly causing injury
that results in a miscarriage or still
birth or knowingly and recklessly
causing serious bodily injury to a
person under the age of 13.
neither are we talking about an 18 year
old getting caught with a joint in the
glove compartment we're talking about
someone who is found guilty of the
felony conviction of manufacturing
selling or purchasing transporting or
possessing with the intent to sell
controlled substances that they're not
authorized to have
while i understand that there are times
particularly early in a person's life
when they make a mistake
and when somebody turns their life
around
i also recognize that there are
consequences for an individual's actions
and that sometimes those consequences
may prevent someone from doing something
that they want to do
i know attorney fenton is with us this
morning and that she has a wealth of
knowledge and examples that she can
share with you
if you have specific questions regarding
the importance of this proposed
legislation or legal aspects she's your
gal
i too am happy to answer any questions
that you may have at this time and if i
am able
thank you thank you very much
representative are there questions for
representative mullen
sure yes represent luna thank you very
much uh mr chair thank you very much
representative mullen for uh for
introducing this uh legislation
one of the things that you mentioned um
um well a lot of it piqued my interest
but uh but one of the things you talked
about was the um the interest in uh in
attaining a new hampshire teacher
certification and using it in other
states
and i was wondering if you could sort of
expand on that a little bit more and and
how this applies
or how this does or doesn't apply to to
the certification process uh well you
know the intricacies of licensing in new
hampshire uh representative luna
that that information came to attention
came to our attention last year when we
were discussing human trafficking
and it was attorney fenton who obviously
raised the concern
in the next hearing that we have we'll
talk a little bit about senate bill 134
which last year added uh the section
five offenses to credentialing in the
state of new hampshire
so anything that is added to the section
five list
with regards to
generic employment
will ultimately end up on the list of
section five offenses that prevent
credentialing as well
are there further questions of
representative mullen yes represent
hobson
thank you for taking my question uh what
happens to what would anyone fall into
the category of this new offense that's
currently employed
here and
what will i believe the short answer to
that may be yes but i will uh ask you
representative hopson to raise that
question with attorney fenton when she's
in the hot seat thank you
do we have a card for rep
for
you don't want us to comment on that
uh
are there any other questions for
representative mullin before we invite
our prosecutor to sit down at the hot
table
yes represent lakers
on the uh possession of a cold
of a controlled drug with intent to sell
is there any kind of
limit on quantity or on
statute of limitations
just thinking like you said
you're stupid you're in school you're
not planning on selling or distributing
but you got five friends who said hey
while you're there can you pick me up
whatever and so all you you you've
brought it back and and and they
reimbursed you
for your expense
um not saying anybody should do that but
i'm just saying
you know 10 years 15 years down the road
is that going and they decide oh they
have a real gift for teaching
i know that there is a time table for
expunging somebody's record
but again i'll let attorney fenton speak
to that representative lakers so that i
don't give you misinformation thank you
you're welcome thank you very much
thank you
um
the distinction between employment and
credentialing is there something in here
that
that i don't know about or just i'm
unaware of yeah employment refers to
anybody that works for a school district
so the credentialing is only uh only
applies to teachers and administrators
would this affect their credentialing
could someone lose their teaching
certificate
through a process like that perhaps uh
that can be answered by the yeah i think
we'll let uh we'll let attorney fenton
take that as well okay
thank you very much representative
mullin
welcome
good morning for the record my name is
diana fenton i'm an attorney with the
department of education um thank you for
having us today and thank you
representative mullen for bringing this
bill forward this
does continue the department's
initiatives in child safety so
commissioner edelblut thanks you for
your attention to this bill this is a
bill that he and i have worked on and
discussed quite a bit
i want to address some of the questions
that have come up regarding employment
versus licensure
rsa 189 13 a deals exclusively with
employment
prior to last year's legislative session
when the department issued a credential
to someone to teach
they did not do any kind of criminal
history background check
the background check was exclusive to
the area the realm of employment only
so what we recognized at the department
was a couple of items of concern
the first is the department was in the
position where a state agency was
issuing a license to someone to be
around children to teach
without doing that criminal background
check potentially
licensing someone who might have been
unemployable pursuant to this list of
disqualifying offenses
as a state agency we were troubled by
that practice and we felt that that did
not support the field of education and
that did not lift up the field of
education
secondarily
we did as representative mullen alluded
to
out of curiosity we looked at
where our credentials were going
and we realized that we took in about a
quarter million dollars of credentialing
fees
from individuals who had no association
with the state of new hampshire no new
hampshire
residents no new hampshire teaching
assignment
and what's interesting and i'll share
this with the committee is we excluded
all the northeast states to include new
york
and yet we were still pulling in a
quarter million dollars in credentialing
fees from
out of out of state from other parts of
the country and we weren't sure why
we're still not sure why but we wonder
if it's because new hampshire teaching
credential did not require a criminal
history background check and perhaps
people were using that
license
to gain reciprocity in other states and
we were concerned not just about new
hampshire child safety but all
children's safety so as an agency we
worked very hard and worked in close
communication with our partners at the
department of safety and
senators and representatives to bring
forward last session senate bill 134
senate bill 134
established 189 13 c
think of it as kind of a conjunction
with 189 13 a
189 13 c
allows the department of education to
run a criminal history check on
first-time applicants for employment
i emphasize first-time applicants
because it is not being done
retroactively for people who already
have a credential they already have a
vested interest in that license
but moving forward
for first-time applicants the department
will do that background check
the department is only screening for the
offenses that you have in front of you
those section 5 violations that's what
if someone has one of those section 5
violations and you should have that list
i call it my cheat sheet list but these
are the crimes which bar employment
you'll see it's homicide it's child
pornography
it's felonious sexual assault which is
new hampshire's version of rape
anything that would bar someone from
being employed we would not credential
them because we don't want to license
however
there are a lot of offenses that are not
on this list for example dwi
arson
things of that nature criminal trespass
and school districts have always had
more discretion to look
into the record
at length and so they can use their
discretion to say this person wants to
be a first grade teacher and yet they
have you know
a number of dwis or domestic violence
assaults that are concerning maybe it's
not the right fit for our school for
this particular position and so the
school district has that
ability to to do that discretion the
department however does not and i think
that's a very important distinction
i'm happy to take any questions on
that dynamic and structure that the
department is currently establishing and
then we can turn our attention to
the subject of this particular i have
one question then i'll let the committee
ask questions to you
diana we have reciprocity with a number
of states yes
and we have a person let's say coming
from maine which we have reciprocity
with me
yes
what kind of check do we do they have
certification there so now we're saying
do they automatically get this
certification what do we do we do a
background check or do we have the
main do a background check or do you do
that how does that work
so moving forward pursuant to senate
bill 134 which was passed last session
the department of education new
hampshire's department of education will
be doing a background check on that
individual whether they come from maine
or minnesota or they're coming right out
of saint anselm's college from a teacher
prep program
we will be doing that criminal
background check not only is that a new
hampshire background check but also the
federal
background check
we also run individuals through the
nationwide database
it's called nasdaq
i always thought it was a stock market
reference but it turned out i was wrong
it took me a couple of years to get up
to speed on that one but it is a an
organization that tracks
educators nationwide who have gotten in
trouble in their own states
and then perhaps seek to move to another
state and so again it's called nasdaq
and
the new hampshire department of
education will run a query through
nasdaq to see if that individual has had
any issues in other states nationwide
thank you very much
members of the committee representative
tanner
thank you mr chair and thank you
attorney fenton um
when we were doing this before with
employees we had an issue with bus
drivers
substitute teachers
people who move
throughout the district and were getting
hammered with criminal background checks
every time they turned around
has anything been done to solve that
issue
yes thank you for the question um we
have successfully uh perhaps i i hate to
use the word solved it feels so arrogant
and i just wait for someone to call me
and say we still have a problem so i'm
going to use that term very loosely but
we have um
we're get we're going to use the term
addressed we have adequately addressed
the bus driver issue and so what we have
done is um
and i want to just back up a step and
give a little historical context one of
the issues we are having with bus
drivers which representative tanner
knows very well
is
typically they are owned by private
companies so for example it might be
butler's bus service it's not owned by
the school district it's owned by a
private company and what happened around
2018 2019
is that the fbi record the nationwide
criminal history check
could no longer be dispersed to
a private company butler's bus service
for example
because they were a non-governmental
entity
but we realized in working with the bus
lobby that the department of education
is a governmental entity
and so we created uh statutorily 189 13b
which allows for the department of
education to issue a
clearance a criminal history clearance
to bus drivers so the department of
motor vehicles license them to drive
that falls outside of the department's
purview as one would suspect
they are licensed to drive a bus and
they get their cdl and then they come to
the department of education and we do a
clearance that clearance is good
statewide
and pun intended this gives the bus
drivers mobility to move from district
to district to district so if
district 1 has a field trip
all of a sudden they can call the second
district and say do you have any bus
drivers that are available and those
individual school districts do not have
to run
background checks on these individuals
so we're just starting that program
we've just put our rules in place and
we've just gotten the approval from the
fbi um so i can't say that it's again
pun intended up and running quite yet
but we are very very close to doing that
up
uh congratulations because we think
you've done that a lot
um
what about substitute teachers
and other uh you know now a lot of
schools are getting cleaning agencies
because
of covid
what about all these other people that
are
third party or even
you know later today we're gonna i think
we hit the
bill on
big buses the premier buses that are
hired for you know field trips and and
sporting events what about those are
they still in kind of no man's land or
so i i can't speak to private bus
companies um a little bit out of my
realm of authority here um but you have
identified that there remains an
overarching issue
in the field of education because there
are so many people who go through the
school doors it's so surprising to me
when you think about how many people
enter a school and we recognize the
importance of those criminal history
background checks that's never up for
debate
but then the question becomes how do we
make sure that everyone has access to
get into these schools
but it's not becoming overly burdensome
i think that the
the department
can play a very critical role because
again we are a governmental entity
i am always the first to say
we need to be very thoughtful about how
we establish this i'm always the one
kind of holding things back a little bit
admittedly
because i want to make sure that
anything the department takes on that we
can do so successfully because if we
mess up kids are harmed
and that is not okay that is not okay
with me or commissioner edelblut and so
we are very thoughtful in our process on
taking on those additional
entities
but we recognize that
that is a very i think critical role
that the department
can play but we haven't played it
historically
and so anytime we kind of pivot and
shift the role that we play or the
service that we provide um we really
have to do so
thoughtfully um because the implications
of it i think are too grave if we don't
so substitute teachers in short
representative tanner are kind of next
on our list if you will we're looking at
how we can help the field in that in
that area
we did have a bill presented last week i
believe in senate education
that will help facilitate substitute
teachers a little bit has nothing to do
directly with the department of
education
let's see if others have any are there
any other questions from the rest of the
committee if not we'll go with
representative cornell thank you and
thank you for taking my question um in
the top line it says school volunt
designated school volunteer would that
include people safe that are doing the
predna program or learn everywhere that
have been
okay to provide those out of school
programs that kids will get credit for
in school
thank you for the question um
the short answer is i'm not entirely
sure i know the term designated
volunteer is defined by each individual
district the law 18913a
gives deference to districts to define
what a designated volunteer could be so
the best example i can give is if i go
to my child's school for
a halloween party i'm not a designated
volunteer i'm there for one occasion i
don't have individual access to children
but if i am to participate on a weekly
basis in a program
then i would presumably fall under the
designated volunteer
i don't
know i i believe that those individual
programs that you listed have their own
um background check policies pursuant to
them i know that is very near and dear
to uh the department's heart um and it
is our top priority quite simply child
safety is always the department's top
priority however individual districts
could account for those programs within
their individual
policies of designated volunteers
thank you uh further questions
yes representative nelson
thank you mr chairman
how about i'll use tin mountain
conservation what happens if they put on
a program in a local school is there any
check on that
again that would depend on the
designated volunteer
policy at that particular school
if it's a
in speaking in general terms if it is a
one-time interaction in the school
that might fall outside of that term
designated volunteer but if you look at
189 13 a
the statute gives deference to
individual school districts
a few years ago when this committee
started looking and revising 18913a
a lot of school districts had the
opportunity to revamp their designated
volunteer policy they had not looked at
it in quite a bit and so this
committee's work on this important topic
spurred a lot of districts to revise
that and look at what that term meant so
at one district to answer your question
representative nelson at one district
they could define tin mountain as
uh as a designated volunteer and ask
them to have a background check and the
next district over could say no we feel
comfortable
not having them go through that process
thank you further questions okay going
back to represent tanner
thank you mr chair um
i'm wondering about charter schools
where only 50 of the teachers have to be
credentialed
are the other 50 percent considered
long-term subs or
how how exactly
do they
they don't have to apply for a
credential
to teach in a in a charter school so
how how does that work and and what kind
of rule changes are there for that
so i think it's important to recognize
when you look at 189 the structure we've
created 189 a is employment and so
whether i'm a credentialed educator
working at a charter school or i'm not i
am still subject to the background check
upon employment and that's critical and
that does not waver that does not change
across the board
189 13 b
addresses the bus drivers and my little
cheat sheet way is b for bus driver
and 189 13 c c for credentialing
that's real insight into my brain but
that's statutorily how we've created it
and it makes sense a b c and you have
all these different designations but for
charter schools whether they are
credentialed or they're not
everyone who steps into that school
is subject to that that employment or
18913a you are there further questions
for the department
not seeing any thank you very much for
your insights and your expertise we
appreciate it it's my pleasure thank you
very much
represent lakers do you have your hand
up
i'm sorry you were then going to go on
to the specifics of this bill and the
questions we asked on it sure
like
asking about
possession of a controlled drug and is
that
is there any kind of
like lower limit be underneath which
they you know are we going for
big time drug dealers are we going for
the stupid kid who made a mistake in
college when they were experimenting and
picked up some drugs for their friends
thank you for the question um to be
clear
it's interesting to the department when
you look at this list of crimes which
bar employment and education
there are no drug offenses on this list
there are no drug offenses and yet
we're putting people in contact with
with children which is a high-risk
population and we all recognize that
the department's intent is not
to target
um people who made a mistake or had
simple
misdemeanor level possession
this this bill before you does not it is
not intended to target um
personal possession personal use
anything like that what we're trying to
do with this bill is recognize that
there are the offenses of possession
with intent to distribute
or
possession with intent to sell either
way you want to put it in that offense
felony level
we feel is concerning enough
to keep away from our classroom and our
children but that is why you see this
additional
language in this proposed bill before
you because we really wanted to make it
clear what the intent was that we wanted
to go for this possession with intent to
distribute we feel that that is a crime
that we want out of the classroom and
away from children
thank you very much
not seeing any further hands uh
appreciate it once yes representative
hall
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question so what happens to
the existing employee a lot of this
seems to be about that person getting
employed so i've been working in the
district for 30 years and i did
something 10 years ago and i never
reported it even though maybe the school
district policy says i must report it
but i didn't
and they've just come upon it do i am i
shown the door right then or
so
this bill would not be applied
retroactively
and i think that's really the crux of
your question
um
this would not suddenly i i do not
envision that this bill would suddenly
require school districts to then
re-fingerprint the law is clear it is
upon employment um any change that we
have made to 189 13 a over the past five
or six years has not ever been
interpreted retroactively so this would
be moving forward
um
upon new employment and if someone moves
from one district to another district
they would be subject to 189 13 a
in the employment provision
thank you thank you very much further
questions
not seeing in hands thank you very much
thank you
we have no further cards on this so we
will call this hearing
closed
and we will now get ready to go into the
next bill which is hb 1234
relative to criminal background checks
for an applicant for a teaching
credential
welcome representative mullen thank you
very much mr chair once again my name is
sue mullen and i represent the people of
hillsborough county district 7 the town
of bedford
house bill 1234 and i like just saying
house bill one two three four
is a
primarily a housekeeping bill in 2021
this body unanimously approved adding
human trafficking to the list of section
5 offenses that prevent employment in
new hampshire public school districts
schools charters and academies that
measure was signed into law by the
governor and went into effect in the
fall
subsequent to that happening the senate
passed legislation omnibus senate bill
that created a new section to rsa 189-13
section c
which we just learned from attorney
fenton stands for credentialing
that lists all the section 5 prohibited
offenses and how they apply to
credentialing
uh they left off 6633.7
human trafficking
because uh it was a little bit like
ships passing in the night
house bill 1234 would rightfully add
633.7
human trafficking to the list of section
5 offenses
i'm sure attorney fenton will answer any
questions that you may have if i can't
uh and i will be happy to take any
questions thank you very much
representative mullen are you half
attorney
pardon me are you half attorney uh
perhaps yeah you're doing a great job by
perhaps thank you um so um
from the committee are there any
questions for representative mullen yes
represent tanner
so this may be thank you for taking my
question um and did you stay at a uh
uh express
um hotel last night holiday in express
last night
i did not
well then okay um
so
uh representative or attorney fenton
mentioned that there is a national
clearinghouse i think nasdaq the one she
the
stock market
what happens to again
charter school teachers educators who
are not credentialed because we know
that only 50 of them are credentialed or
have to be
um do they go into a database as well i
wish i could answer that question for
you but playing stump the representative
representative tanner has worked for you
i just want to make sure representing
fenton got a chance at the mic again i'm
sure she'd be happy to answer that
question thank you
okay any further questions for
representative mullen
represent hobson
sorry just one quick question and thank
you um did you do you have a copy of
that um
list of offenses here i do is it extra
further further questions for
representative mullin
thank you very much you're quite welcome
are diana you also a
information for this one too
uh if the committee has any questions i
okay uh attorney uh
fenton is here representing tanner
thank you uh so i think you heard my
question before but i'll restate it you
said the nasdaq or
close to nasdaq is a national national
uh database for teachers
i assume that mean credential teachers
so i was wondering uh in charter schools
where only 50 percent have to be
credentialed but they are full-time
teachers and they're working in the
public school system
would they then go in if they fail to
meet the cri the
criminal background checks do they go
into that database
so
thank you for the question for the
record my name is diana fenton i'm an
attorney with the department of
education
a couple of things
as it pertains to charter schools last
session a bill was passed
which made the code of conduct
applicable to charter schools so we are
working with charter schools on on that
particular issue
um i don't recall the number off the top
of my head but it made the code of
conduct applicable to charter schools as
an entity recognizing that not everyone
within a charter school employment wise
is credentialed
as far as nasdaq goes
someone is only entered into nasdaq not
because they pass a background check or
they don't pass a background check
they're entered into nasdaq if there's a
finding of educator misconduct
which
presumably other states would want to
know about it it's not directly linked
when representative mueller said you
played stump the representative i
thought i think he played stump the
lawyer too because
our actions of the department of
education are narrowly tailored to
credential holders
and so
while part of me was inclined to say i
think that individual could
in theory presumably still be entered
into nasdaq
i will have to get back to you with that
answer because if someone doesn't have a
credential
the department doesn't have jurisdiction
over them and we've had this
conversation with districts as we
receive
calls
with allegations of violations of the
code of conduct it's part of our inquiry
and vetting out cases so for example we
deal with para educators some para
educators are credentialed some of them
are not and so we will simply say is
that person credentialed are they not um
i cannot recall an instance in which we
had someone
not credentialed and we took action upon
them because we can't
uh so i'm not familiar with that
particular fact pattern typically
representative tanner we will find some
kind of documentation in our eis system
whether it's a statement of eligibility
or something that will give us the
department jurisdiction over that
individual so
you played stump the representative and
won and you won at stump the lawyer as
well so you're doing quite well and it's
not even noon um i will have to get back
to you on that uh
representative fenton i i do have a
question for him follow up to where i'm
not a representative
okay well we we've just upgraded your
pay i'm fantastic i'll have to let frank
know i don't know if he's ready so uh in
the bill we just did
that bill uh when we're dealing with
employment
also reflected rsa
633 colon 7.
so this bill is adding 633 colon 7 so is
it fair to say that that any employee
is accountable to that rsa 633 colon 7.
yes so last session human trafficking
which is rsa 633 colon 7 that was added
to the list of disqualifiers
in the employment section
because we were in the process
legislatively of creating 189 13c
and because of that this this before you
didn't exist
for
for us to add the human trafficking
offense and so this really is a cleanup
bill we want to recognize the importance
of having consistency
in the disqualifiers whether it be in
employment or in credentialing there has
to be that consistency there cannot be
discrepancy between the two lists and
it's interesting to share with this
committee
that
there was a gentleman an educator
it was in the press he
pled guilty back in september of 2021 of
last year he pled guilty to human
trafficking
right here in merrimack county he pled
guilty to human trafficking and i heard
that on wmur where everyone in new
hampshire gets their news and i grabbed
my phone and i looked up the effective
date of representative mullen's bill and
it had become effective signed into law
the day before
that gentleman pled guilty and so
representative mullen was kind enough to
take a phone call from me at 6 30 in the
morning and she has never answered my
calls since
because i was so excited that all of a
sudden we saw it all come together this
gentleman will not teach in a new
hampshire school because he pled guilty
to uh the offense of human trafficking
um and it
i wanted to share that with this
committee that it was this committee's
work that that made that possible and
recognize the importance of it um i
think when we hear that offense of human
trafficking we are inclined to say well
that doesn't happen here in new
hampshire um and sadly we recognize that
it that it does and
so really
what this bill in front of you does
is recognize the importance of that
offense of human trafficking recognizing
how dangerous that would be to have that
in a classroom and more importantly
while by putting it in this particular
section 189 13 c
we are telling people
if you are applying for a credential in
the state of new hampshire to teach
children
you will not be licensed to teach if you
have that offense on your criminal
record
that's what this bill does represent
cordelia
thank you mr chair and thank you
represent i mean attorney fenton
um
why not add
318 b
to control substance intent to sell
to the credentialing section as well
at this point this bill
belongs to the committee so i will leave
that in your discretion
but i think it is important to recognize
and not conflate the different sections
um and if this committee were to pass
the bill that it just heard 1311 then
presumably we will be before you next
session uh asking to add those into the
other sections but as this bill now
belongs to this committee that is
certainly um
amendment that you could take up
but i appreciate the opportunity to
explain some of the initiatives the
department is undertaking in this
important area
thank you representative ford
here mike you're mike thank you
mike
thank you for taking my question
i'm sitting here puzzling
a predicament that we had a number of
years ago when i was an academic vice
president
and we had large numbers of people
graduating with degrees in education who
never
ever
applied for a credential as a teacher
and we were trying to figure out why are
we training these people to be teachers
when they have no intention of teaching
and
it turned out that there's a fair amount
of demand in industry for people with
that subset of credentials or
capabilities
and then i move that back a step and
we're talking about protecting the
teachers but we don't do it only until
they apply to be a teacher
but before they become that
they're in the schools
and we have not done a background check
on them and so my question simply given
that factor out i just gave you is maybe
we should consider or do you think we
should consider
doing the same background check with
people who enroll in a teacher
preparation program
thank you very much for the question um
so part of senate bill 134
not only addressed first-time teaching
applicants applying to the department of
education but also
addressed the issue of teacher prep
program candidates
we had a similar issue look at
colleges such as saint anselm's they
could not get that federal background
check because they are a
non-governmental entity and so
the department of ed stepped in and we
are working to take on that role whereby
we work with
the institutes of higher education those
teacher prep programs and we will do
similar to the bus drivers a clearance
for those individuals to go into various
districts
you know i think it's important to
recognize that the individual districts
still have the right to do their own
background check
they are allowing people into their
schools to be around their children and
they have the liability they have the
opportunity to do that but that is a
role that the department is currently
working to take on um so i really
appreciate that question because it is
an area of concern and we did recognize
that last session and take steps to
address it the best we could thank you
thank you representative uh
you will keep promoting me i'm gonna get
a call from you i'm gonna get you a rank
really fast
yeah
yeah um i thought we addressed that when
we talked about the student student
teachers
uh and the fees that they had to pay for
this before they got into the classroom
so one of the considerations was the
nature of the fees what what was
happening in the field
is if i was a teacher prep program
candidate
at a college
i
could in theory be paying multiple
fees and multiple instances to get my
background check
to go into these various schools and it
was just simply becoming untenable and
so the thought was if we could kind of
house it in a central location right
utilize the department of education to
serve that important role to facilitate
this
then it could in theory be a one-time
background check one-time costs and fee
however we do have to recognize that
districts will always retain the right
to do those additional background checks
and they have every right to do that
and recognize the the safety issue there
so does it completely solve the problem
i can't say that it does but is it
another avenue by which the department
is trying to address these issues
identify these issues and address them
by working with our partners in the
field absolutely thank you
thank you
representatives
thank you i just have a quick question
and that is how long do these fbi
background checks take because you know
if you've got a student teacher and they
take a month or two to do them and
they're trying to do it on a term it
could mean they effectively can't go in
the classroom that term
so
thank you for the question
it my hesitation is only because i
do not work for the department of safety
and i hesitate to speak on their behalf
but i can tell you that the department
of safety has taken a lot of
initiatives to speed up the process of
the background check and i think that
was pretty common across the board is
the delay
but again the department of safety has
tried to address that issue pretty
quickly i think a month turnaround would
be surprisingly long
and i think the background check
turnaround is now
within a week but again i'm going to
couch that by saying i do not work for
the department of safety
so i have to be careful in in that
testimony but i can say that they are
aware of that issue that issue's been
brought to their attention and we at the
department of ed have worked very um
very closely with our partners at the
department of safety and they've worked
with the education field to address
those concerns
represented tanner
no i know you're going to hate this
question
well you already stumped the lawyer once
so
again with charter schools they they
don't have a superintendent that this
the governmental setup isn't the same as
districts so do they have the discretion
to uh
run
background
so the difference in the structure at a
charter school is recognized within the
statute 189-13a
and they they say the chief executive
so in terms of the discretion whether or
not to run a background check
i don't believe there is any discretion
when i look at the statute 189 13a as it
applies to charter schools and public
schools
in my reading of the statute the law is
very clear that it applies
regardless of the credential
whether there's a credential or there's
not
it applies to equally to charter schools
um just so they're considered a
governmental agency like the
superintendent is i mean that that was
one of the
little glitches when we were working
with it before that um you know certain
groups couldn't couldn't run the checks
so the certain groups that can't run the
checks we've identified as being like a
private bus company things of that
nature i am not aware of any charter
school having an issue getting those
background checks and and something like
prenda
uh with the pods uh are they able to run
background checks my understanding is
they are we've actually worked very
closely with prenda and the department
of safety we had some um
meetings with uh dos and prenda this
past summer um i participated in those
meetings where we addressed those those
areas so um
yeah we were able to address those
concerns okay thank you thank you
thank you very much are there further
questions of attorney fenton
you downgraded me well we'll upgrade you
okay well thank you very much diana and
you're always appreciated and we uh
thoroughly enjoy what you have to offer
us thank you
further questions
from the so i see none and i have no
further pink cards on this so we will
yeah and uh the next hearing starts in a
relative to requirements for teacher
uh
no we really don't we have about three
um
yes
what day is tomorrow oh it's only
there's a lot going on
yeah tomorrow's the day i got to get my
news i have a biennial page i write up
in my neck of the woods
every thursday i gotta write an article
and it's just you know every day every
other every other thursday
oh i'm
sorry i've found is very nice um so i
write for our newsletter but i write as
school board plus yeah yeah it's too
many so now i reach out to sean at the
majority office
oh good there you go sean's good john's
yeah
he even is preemptive now where he'll
say it's that time of month uh here's
what i have for you
that's great maybe i'll tag into him
someday when i just don't have time i
need to ask him for help with the
i'm only scratching
who's
when you look at
part a there which deals with employment
the teachers all employed public schools
charters are public
okay we're going to go ahead now it is
11 30. we're going ahead with
13.72
this is relative to the requirements for
teacher certification
and
do we have the
okay representation is the prime sponsor
when you have an opportunity you know
we'd like to get one of these filled out
but you can do it when you're done okay
thank you mr chairman
for the record i'm representative john
genigean representing rockingham
district 8 which is salem
today's today's bill 1372 relatively
straightforward
relative to requirements for teacher
certification
one of the things that's
been found
to be true is a lot of newer teachers
especially
don't seem to be up on the education
rules
and
as i'm sure all you know
education rules are are pretty critical
for teachers to understand as they deal
with such things as minimum education
standards and a whole myriad of other
items that that
relate to education of students and and
other things
um
i'm not going to say a whole lot about
this um stephen
uh steve appleby the director of um
the division of education standards and
higher ed we'll
we'll be speaking to you as well
and he mentioned to me yesterday i think
he'll talk about this as well at the end
of the bill where it says that
this will take effect 60 days after
passage
he told me yesterday that's that's a bit
early and he'll be talking to that
looking at probably more like a january
1st
implementation of that but this this
bill basically would require
that teachers
or educators i should say
to be certified need to take a course in
education
in the education rules so they're up on
those things other than that mr chairman
that's all i have to say if anyone has
any questions thank you very much
representative are there questions for
the sponsor of the bill yes
representative cordelli thank you thank
you representative for uh being here
um
rules
to be
made a part of the process how about the
the certainly it's important for them
for them to know the statutes as well um
if this i'm certainly open to this bill
being modified in in
some way which would we certainly want
teachers to have a comprehensive
understanding
of
the laws as well as the rules
uh represent i have a question for you
um i'm holding up one set of rules right
here minimum standards for public school
approval
these are rules we have rules for
transportation we have rules for
career technical education we have rules
for
just about anything a school does
and so we'll be talking about another
book that's the size of our statutory
language
right there
um
how is it possible for
uh
for a teacher like myself
to and why is it important
that i have to know about
transportation
or some topic which is not
relevant to the instruction curriculum
and working with parents in the
well that's uh certainly a good question
i think
as we look at
you know teachers starting off uh
teaching kids that's probably not that
important however many teachers
will eventual or some teachers will
eventually move up to higher positions
whether it's
superintendent of schools or
department chairs or whatever it is and
may you know maybe there's you raise a
good point maybe there's maybe there's
there needs to be some more language
here but i think
it certainly is important for some of
those who move on
to higher positions to understand those
thank you
representative cornell
thank you and thank you for taking my
question as chairman ladd said this is
what is now in law and this is from 2021
we as a committee have not gotten our
copy of the the latest
rules from last year so i'm wondering
how you would find somebody to teach
this that would have the most recent
laws and
be able to do it its rules
um that's a good question i wasn't aware
of that
and and
perhaps i don't want to put this on him
but maybe when uh mr appleby is up here
he can
answer that question um but or maybe you
know and i'd love to work with any
member of the committee to
to make this something that is doable
because at the end of the day
it is important some there are certain
there's certainly much in the education
rules that are critical for teachers to
know
uh minimum education standards and
things like that i mean it would be
you know a travesty i think if if a
teacher or an educator does not
understand those things and is teaching
and what is the point to having all
these education rules if we're not going
to follow them
representative porter and then
representative wolf thank you mr chair
and thank you for taking my question sir
um do you know that these things aren't
being taught now to prospective teachers
in the classes um that they're taking
for example
if i'm training to be an elementary
school teacher are you sure that the
coursework that i'm taking does not
include some of the rules that you
no i'm not sure but
the it is not it's not a requirement so
depending on the course itself of course
those standards
or not those standards but what is
taught could vary obviously from from
school to school the the evidence is
that um
through people i've talked to and others
there's evidence that
there are teachers that that have no
idea what the minimum education
standards are
um and and maybe this maybe this becomes
a bill focusing on that i i don't want
to just decide that obviously right now
but i think there definitely needs to be
a discussion
thank you very much i'm wondering how
you envision this happening because if
you've got a student that's educated out
of state and they want to apply for
credentialing here do they have to then
defer their credentialing for three
months while they take a course on the
rules of the state of new hampshire
and to one end because for example i
know my daughter who's a first grade
teacher was educated at boston college
both her teaching degree and her
master's in education and while she was
not educated specifically on the rules
of new hampshire law she's most
certainly in her child development
classes and all the curriculum classes
she took was educated and what the basic
standard is that she needs to teach her
first grade kids to get them reading so
i'm at a loss as to what it is that's so
specific about the new hampshire
standards it's important and i'm at a
loss as to understand how somebody
educated out of state is supposed to
i mean all i can say is there's the the
education rules
and minimum standards are there for re i
mean the rules have been created i
if somebody's from out of state um
if this is new hampshire's uh law
then
they would have to you know abide by it
and they would need to take a course
i mean i guess it's it'd be similar to
you know a realtor let's say
i mean there's a myriad of different
examples but you know realtors licensed
in a certain state
they don't automatically just get to go
be licensed in another state without
sometimes they have to take some some
courses and
and then take the testing so i i think
when we're talking about
out of state
i would just imagine they need to follow
thank you
when i did my teacher certification
i took a course called teacher in the
law and we talked about federal law
state law
rules how that applied to what we needed
to be doing we did not cover
all of this
we couldn't have we covered the basics
and
now it's been
i don't want to say how many years but
it's been quite a few years
this all keeps changing year to year so
how do you
you know so okay when i was accredited i
you know got my certification i learned
all of this stuff a lot of it doesn't
apply anymore
well base based on a lot of the um
questions and commentary i'm hearing
i've been hearing since i've been up
here it sounds like
there needs to be a focus
in in
what may be deemed the most important
area which to me would be minimum
education standards to make sure that
students have at least the minimum
obviously
teachers can go way beyond the minimum
but it sounds to me maybe maybe this
should be a bill where we're focusing on
the minimum education standards of
students
further questions representative waltz
thank you
it would seem to me that most teachers
are teaching from curriculum directed by
the district in which they teach and
that the director of curriculum should
be the one that's really focused on the
minimum education standards that that's
their job and then it's the job of the
teacher to follow the curriculum of that
district so that they would not
necessarily have to know the minimum
education standards don't you agree that
i it makes sense but i'd have to think
about that some more
are there any further questions
representative
um thanks very much thanks for joining
us this morning
and uh and for your concern about
students um
being educated to at least the minimum
educational standards um my question
actually the question sort of goes to
that though what are what are your
thoughts as far as
how um
stay you know the average student
statewide
is uh is performing um you know
i guess there's no problem is what
yeah i mean
i don't have data on that my my sense is
that new hampshire is doing fairly well
but i think
always striving to improve further is
certainly would be i think a goal that
would be
always worthwhile
thank you very much other further
questions
not cnn's thank you very much
all right i won't call you
representative appleby
um
are you uh willing to you know
take any questions or do you have
something to offer
we will need pink cards for those which
are
um
are testifying or presenting some
support even on an informational basis
just fill one of these things out just
say information
not either
for or against you don't have to do that
part
welcome
thank you and good morning
representatives and thank you for your
time um steve appleby director of
educator support and higher education at
the department of ed
i oversee
our credentialing educator credentialing
function and uh with me here is
administrator nate green
all right so for the record nate green
department of education uh i'm here to
support steve on this particular bill as
i oversee the minimum standards and
administrative rules for schools uh so
sort of the teacher certification side
and administrative rules side
thank you i was hoping to potentially
maybe answer a few of the questions that
i just heard um to shed some light on
today we have 12
institutions of higher education in our
state that are approved by the state
board of education to
have teacher programs right educator
preparation programs and
nowhere in our state rule do we require
them to teach anything to do with new
they do teach classes for example
special ed candidates go through special
ed law classes
the majority of that focuses on federal
requirements
very little of that is state
putting something in statute that would
require the programs to teach something
about new hampshire rules
seems logical to us from the standpoint
that it
um
everyone comes out of school at the same
level
additionally there was a comment about
out of state currently many other states
have state specific requirements so when
an educator moves to that state for
example georgia
if you move to georgia and you want to
teach in georgia you have to take a
georgia history class
in order to get your teaching license
so what's the solution we don't want to
create a bottleneck or a shortage any
worse than it already is
we have already in existence an intern
license program
an educator can come here if they
haven't met all the requirements they
can start in the classroom immediately
on an intern license they can complete
their requirements and then apply for
full licensure
so we envision if this law were to pass
that we could use that for out-of-state
educators
the ask of moving the effective date out
was at our request because this will
give
our programs time to develop and
implement a class
so that
our current folks in the pipeline don't
miss a beat
the
informal survey i did of some of the
ihes said that january 1st was doable
so hence the date there
as far as the law is always changing i
heard that question was a great question
they do change every year we know that
as best of anyone
and all i would say there is many
requirements change every year and
perhaps in this bill we should address
professional development
because
if you think about curriculum that's
taught today
every three years our educators have to
have professional development to
recertify
so perhaps that could be something that
could be added
that maybe it's professional development
the last piece and then i'll let nate
take over would be
administrators
number of our educators will go down
into administration whether that's
principal special ed director
maybe someday superintendent
and while it does not seem to make sense
to teach a teacher about
busing and transportation rules
it may make sense if they go for an
advanced certification that they have to
learn it then
so again perhaps maybe in the bill
we could break out several tiers
of what would be required
so teachers minimum standards
administrators maybe need to know more
advanced topics
that would be a suggestion
so and i'm going to turn it over nate to
to speak to some of that as well from
the minimum standard site
[Music]
i don't know i think you answered most
of the i'm not sure what else i can add
to that
uh unless there are additional questions
i'm happy to take
okay okay so i'll open up with a
question then i'll move it around the
committee here
um
of course i've i've had the courses on
school law but it was generic in my
master's program because i was going for
administration and supervision
um
finance as well however if i'm a speech
pathologist in myrtle beach
and i'm looking to come where the
climate is wonderful and it's always
warm up here in new hampshire
and
i'd like to know why
when i as a speech pathologist and very
familiar with the regulations associated
with idea
which are federal
and which are very comparable in most
states except this state which we go
above and beyond
but why
would i then have to go through this
hurdle
to
take some kind of a
assessment or that when we are already
shy in the state speech pathologists or
life skills teachers
or even now
teacher teachers in the elementary
school in the high school
which uh
due to the situation we have with covid
so i i just under i'm just
wondering why
um
this has to be done on a state level i'm
sure that
at a local level if there's something
pertinent to what they're doing in that
classroom that's relevant as far as a
rule that it can be explained by that
supervisor in that school
i'm just having difficulty understanding
sure um i mean i can provide some
theoretical examples um and i you know
same as you you know i didn't you know
really become introduced to uh any kind
of public school law until i went into
my master's and doctor courses in
education
and so i think sometimes it is difficult
to see from that beginning teacher who's
who's just getting their bachelor's
degree getting their license going into
the classroom
you know why they need to know new
hampshire specific
rules and statutes and laws
um i think one thing that it has the
potential to do for teachers is it opens
up the possibility for innovation
because when we go out and we meet with
schools and we talk to them you know if
you're a school that is a low-performing
school you're looking for strategies to
reach out to your students
oftentimes teachers and administrators
feel like they have to continue to do
things the same way they've always done
them because that's what's required by
administrative rule that's what's
required by statute there's an
assumption that business is the way that
it is because that's what's required by
the state and an unfamiliarity with some
of our administrative rules and some of
our statutes prevents teachers i think
from seeing where in rural and where in
statute they can deviate and where they
can take advantage of areas that they
could innovate in the classroom or
within their school or within their
district so as a as a theoretical
possibility i think a greater
familiarity with the structure that we
have in our state opens up to teachers
and knowledge of where they can branch
out and think outside of the box
thank you represent porter
thank you thank you mr chair and i
actually have a couple of questions if
that's all right well let's hear the
first one first
so how do you envision this course i'm a
junior in college and i'm preparing to
to teach elementary school
and
i have to take a course in new hampshire
school law
and new hampshire school rules
it's a full semester course i meet three
days a week for so many hours
who teaches it where do they get the
textbooks how are they tested on it
spread it out show me the course
what's the course like
diving into the intention of this
particular bill or this particular
legislation i think you know we would
need to look at the wording does this
need to be a full course or is the
intention more to provide familiarity
with teachers of administrative roles
and right now i know that the current
bill just talks about administrative
rules as opposed to law and statute
i think it's at its smallest at its most
basic where you can provide the most
benefit across the board is that
familiarity with the minimum standards
administrative rules and so perhaps that
isn't a full course perhaps that's
something that could be included as part
of the curriculum within the teacher
prep program in one of the current
courses that teachers are already taking
i think that's the the smallest lift i
agree if it is a single course a
standalone you would want to be more
expansive than just administrative roles
you would want to go into law and
statute
can i follow up sir yes you may okay so
when i was working toward my cags and my
my
administrative certificate i took a
course in school law
it was like like the chair said it was a
general course it was a full semester
heavy load
as a graduate student with a lot of
would this not be better placed
in training and sort of certificate
granting to at the administrative level
with the understanding that the
administrators are the ones who would
share this knowledge with their
classroom teachers who
to be honest are concerned about wiping
kids noses a lot of time of the day and
that kind of stuff i mean that they have
those down to earth issues to be
concerned about
would this not be better placed for a
certificate for an administrator
i think that it could have placed in
both of those with a different focus
i think absolutely there's a larger
focus when we start talking about things
like transportation and cte education
and things that are not going to be an
immediate priority for most of our
classroom teachers absolutely that
probably has a better place with
administrators
which is why i mentioned i think when we
talk about just the minimum standards
themselves that particular part of
administrative rule probably has the
greatest and broadest reach for the most
educators in the state
thank you
further questions
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking the question we heard earlier
today about credentialing a lot of it
being done for
teachers not even going to teach in new
hampshire and we have reciprocity in
other states
that
got their credentials
none of us
so why would this not be really when a
teacher first applies to a school
that they then have
to read up and know know the laws rather
than at the credentialing
they don't even know where they're going
to teach at and either the reciprocity
thank you for the question i'm just
trying to think about what you're asking
um i apologize
uh
so reciprocity is a term just as a side
note is a term that's used uh in
credentialing around the country
by state departments of education and in
practice there's actually very little
one-to-one reciprocity
there's almost zero instances where
someone comes to new hampshire with a
teacher license
or a principal license hands it to us
and we immediately hand back to them a
local license of comparable nature
what reciprocity does is it makes it
easier for teachers to move between
states but it's not a one for one i
think an example was given before of
real estate or you know there's other
licensing bodies so
as it stands today that
that reciprocity occurs but there's
oversight by the department of the
incoming educator
so that educators transcript and
qualifications are reviewed to meet our
standards and
so
if in fact an educator came here from
another state and this was the law
one of the requirements would be
they would need to take this class
i'm not sure if i answered your question
yeah just follow up but who would be
giving this class i guess is the point
in almost every instance if a
requirement isn't met it's one of our
institutions of higher education that
delivers the class
either as a certificate or a four-credit
class
representative and then representative
thank you mr thank you for being here
and taking our questions uh
i sometimes have to get a license uh
when we rent in lake winnipesaukee uh to
have a boat license for two weeks and
there's a body of knowledge a hand out a
booklet of stuff that i or people like
myself who want that license temporary
license need to study we take the exam
assessment online so we keep hearing
about a course or a class
is there some way that this requirement
perhaps could be met by a simple
um online
assessment
whereby the people are given the body of
knowledge they need to learn and then
they sign in and take it online as
opposed to a class or a course that you
keep describing
thank you for the question
i don't see why not
is the short answer i mean the the bill
doesn't speak to who would develop that
um how we would administer an assessment
there would be a cost associated with
that so there are
a number of pieces but i
i don't see why that couldn't be done
thank you
representative
thanks uh thanks very much and and um
uh question is really to uh to dr green
um you had you had suggested
during your testimony that um
that in particular
uh lower um
low-performing schools may uh may see a
benefit by by having um
a program like this in place and it
would allow teachers to sort of examine
um what their boundaries are and and
think a little more outside the box
and i just wanted if if you could sort
of expand on what you meant by
low performing schools do you mean like
sure i think there's probably a variety
of different ways of looking at that so
you could look at it from a resource
perspective so school districts that say
are struggling to use the resources that
they have available to them could find
ways of administering the minimum
standards in different ways that would
maximize their local resources
or you could look at it from an academic
and an assessment perspective
so school districts that have students
or subgroups of their students that are
performing low on the state assessment
may look at different ways that they
could administer those same minimum
standards in order to reach their
students or provide instruction in a
different manner
in a follow-up yeah for sure um so
thanks so um
so just um just to follow up on that
um there's a there's there's a pretty
clear
connection between um um
free and reduced price lunch populations
or density and um and and student
student outcomes
and
just trying to you know wonder wondering
how
maybe a more concrete knowledge of the
rules would uh would would would somehow
um uh
positively impact
uh those schools with high free and
yeah you're putting me on the spot here
well that's what
that's what being a witness is all about
um
i can give you one example this is
something that you know we've looked at
with a couple of administrators that
have looked to some other states that
have gotten creative with their school
calendars and the way that they schedule
their days
when you look at the minimum standards
themselves we have a variety of
different ways of
measuring out our school calendar year
you can do a school year is 180 days or
you can look at it as a certain number
of instructional hours and that's a
minimum that the schools are required to
provide
and rather than going for 100 what many
of our schools do is they look at that
180 days and then they look at the
length of their day and they try to make
sure that they're measuring the length
of the day so that by the time they get
to the end of 180 days they've met those
hours requirements
there's a variety of other creative ways
that you might schedule that out while
still meeting the hours requirement of
the minimum standards but not
necessarily the 180 days that might
provide more flexibility for different
populations of students in a district
so as one example that's a way that a
school district could get creative using
the minimum standards while still
meeting the regulations that they're
required to
thank you
representative ellison
thank you mr chair thanks for taking my
questions real quick question did the
department request that this bill be
filed
um
frankly i i don't know um representative
canadian reached out and asked uh for
department to come and answer questions
okay so thank you thank you are there
further questions
uh i just have one myself it would it be
i'll get you a second rick for zen like
like us
um
knowing that
i brought this in today not because of
this bill because i have to reference it
later on today
and and i've certainly been here in this
house 14 years in the capacity on the
education committee and i still have to
go to it to reference
wouldn't it be wiser rather than saying
we're going to give you another rope
test and just regurgitate back to us
information that's might be in here
regarding how you operate a kitchen in a
school
that wouldn't it be more important for
the
new certified licensed person in our
state to come in say we have these
statutes here here's where you can go
find them
we have rules which govern what you're
going to be what what areas she should
be covering in a a science class in high
school
and specifically various areas
here's where you go to reference it
rather than having to regurgitate i
don't know how you would ever
develop any kind of an assessment
of of this plus everything else
isn't just wiser that we
teach or ask of our teachers
and our administrators and all those
working that you know where to go to get
i i think the one thing that i would say
and i i agree with you um chairman
the the importance is around
an understanding and a knowledge and
familiarity that the minimum standards
are there that they exist that they
govern the operation of a school
building so i think any way that we can
uh get anybody that's working within our
educational field to have an
understanding both of the fact that the
minimum standards exist but also where
they are and what they do i think that's
important i think there's a variety of
ways of going about doing that whether
it's a course whether it's a test
whether it's a webinar a workshop or a
professional development opportunity
thank you very much
uh further questions from the committee
do you know that the teacher colleges in
new hampshire aren't doing this already
because
i know when i went that was my
understanding that that was part of the
program
in general and
i mean have you actually checked on that
to know that that's not happening
thank you for the question
representative of the
[Music]
uh five
institutions that i spoke with
they're not
so
one at a very high level points out the
website and talks about minimum
standards but there is no real
discussion
thank you very much
further questions from the committee not
saying thank you very much for coming
over
thank you you're welcome
uh we don't do we have any more cards
here
thank you chairman i'll
make this very quick megan tuttle
president of new hampshire um we're here
in opposition to this bill i had a lot
of questions that were written down but
i think everybody here asked them
already so we won't go through them
again so that's all
thank you very much thank you
are there any questions of
megan
hopefully not okay thank you very much
thank you
have a good afternoon good luck
with that i'm going to close this
hearing
and we're going to break for lunch and
we will come back at one o'clock
thank you
excellent testimony by
i think we ought to do this after
later on today let them go get something
to eat right now i think people are
pretty much shot yeah
and let's do that again because someone
the information of everybody here that
yeah
representative moffat was kind enough to
reach up with his height and all to
change that for us
so
yeah
which movement reaching up or to the
clock
okay so with that i'd like to go ahead
and look at the
first uh bill coming up this afternoon
uh here at 1 o'clock
hb 1202
02 relative to transportation pupils to
school activities by a contract carrier
represent boom
thank you mr chairman and representative
of education
this bill remember last year for those
who weren't here
we had a bill last year from the omnibus
bill from the senate stuck in it
and we didn't we learned then
that using coach buses
for travel was actually illegal
even though everybody remembers using
them forever
um
we got hung up last year on the mileage
requirement that was in the bill the
origin original bill from the senate had
75 miles was that was that one-way
round-trip
and we changed it to 150 round-trip but
after we voted it dawned on some of us
that we messed up
when we rushed through bills sometimes
schools use coaches for a lot of trips
less than 75 miles
some examples school field trips
out of state
going to the airport
other overnight events
and
representative leon from last year she's
on on our committee she mentioned to me
about the londonderry marching band
for years have gone multiple events
including the rose bowl inaugurations
etc they go everywhere
with their equipment and suitcases they
need to coach buses
and the airport is only about 50 miles
coach butts i went on a field trip some
years ago to europe coach bus was needed
to the airport other school trips
nature's classroom etc and in most cases
these trips are not paid by taxes
were paid by fundraisers
and
and fees to the to the students it will
not be used for normal school trips
uh one of the problems that we came out
with
why it wasn't used it was of course
uh the bus drivers background checks
they came out well these are all field
trips and who else is on the bus
parents i mean chaperones and teachers
we all had background checks and in some
cases for example
the trips to washington dc
i mean how many different bus drivers
are going to have taking the trip you
don't know what state they're even in so
after that was approved so last
it was recommended that i put in the
bill to get rid of the mileage
proponent and if you see on the bottom
it used to require travel at least 150
miles round trip just taking that out
because we know it's being used for less
than that and there's not no really need
for the mileage requirement and thank
you i'll take any questions
are there any questions from the
committee for representative
yes represent tanner
thank you i'm i'm just wondering thank
you uh for taking my question i'm just
wondering why you added
are approved by the school board that's
in in dark
and what exactly
does that mean as far as
what does the school district approve
well that's already in law
or approve are approved by the school
district
it's it's it's printed as new in the
bill
maybe i'm sorry yeah but yeah if the
school district approves it then
if it's not in law that's what it meant
yes how to be approved by the school
district what are they approving
that you can use the bus for that trip
for that activity
in other words
even though i mean they like the
londonderry marching band for example
they can't just go out and hide the bus
it's got to be approved by the school
district
so so
if i may have a follow-up yes go ahead
thank you so
not to make this too complicated because
it i agree that the mileage should be
increased okay that that's fine i'm just
wondering um
you know
when i've when i've done sports or field
trips or anything like that and we've
we've gotten uh you know a bus a big bus
like you said it happens
um
a lot of times the school pays for it
uh sometimes sometimes the kids raise
the money
to get to get the bus
so
the approval by the school district
like a
group that represents the school
couldn't just go out and raise money
hire the bus and not go through the
school board
i mean everything i mean the school
district that's why it does school board
school district right
i mean it's
everything got to be approved somewhere
i mean you can't just go uh a classroom
can't just say hey we're going to go
here and we'll get a bus
it's all got to be somebody's got to
approve it
so it's got to go up the line and
somebody got to know about it
represent boom i have a question it's a
follow-up to that line of thinking
would it be wise to put a period after
services
and we're in special education
okay
if we want to make that amendment
well i've just asked maybe uh
in you know future
committee to be here they may be able
are questioning they might be able to
further that but that would be you know
something i asked and for you to think
authorized or approved is there a
further questions represent porter
mr chair i'm just i would you repeat
what you're
my mother
my position is as the school principal
yeah no we had the authority to do that
right i i just wanted to know what you
were proposing so the sentence would
just please let me just finish job
training programs field trips and
special education transition services
period
are approved by the school district
now the recipe out
or are you taking it i'm suggesting the
rest is gone okay thank you but yes
except for that last school activities
which is already law
further
uh discussion or questioning from the uh
committee of representative
no
okay
try that
okay not seeing any more so we will
close this hearing
unless do we have any more pink cards i
which one would you want
both of them
okay
welcome representative fenton
senator
you fenton commercial edelblut's going
to have a stern talking to you
once you keep giving me a job here yes
so good afternoon good afternoon so
thank thanks very much for joining us
again miss fenton um
the um uh
when when we uh discussed this uh a
similar uh bill
last year i know there were a number of
concerns i think that brought that that
um sort of followed along the lines of
of student safety
and given the fact that that
two of the bills this morning
that we heard um and that you testified
on were
focused squarely on student safety both
from a criminal background checks in for
an employment but also criminal
background check for um for licensing
uh are there does does
the provision that's in roman 2 the
proposed provision in roman 2
with or without the
the part of the sentence that that
are approved by the school district
does does that bring up any
either concerns or responsibilities
as far as student safety on on
thank you for the question just for the
record my name is dianna fenton i'm an
attorney with the department of
education
i appreciate the question and the short
answer is i would have to i will have to
get back to you i have to think about it
in the in the broader context um when we
look at contract carriers they are
private entities they are private
company um so they would fall under a
contract service
189 13 a as we discussed at length this
morning deals with employee
employment and contractors so
my answer is that
as a contractor if i'm running a bus
service and i am contracting with sau
number one
they would have to
run a background check on me as i am
contracting with them for this service
and i think that is the umbrella of
child safety that it would fall under
would not fall within the department
because we are exclusive to the school
bus
um and this is just kind of a one-time
may i get a follow-up on that yes so
thanks very much and uh and thank you
for your answer
on on that um
uh if the
um
if the bill was
not amended and it included the text are
approved by the school district
um would that place any additional
fiduciary um
uh regards i guess or considerations on
i mean let's say the school board was
approving it and the school board
certainly has a fiduciary responsibility
to um
to
you know the voters the taxpayers the
residents the students you know the the
entire school community
um would it would it would have placed
the school board in um in maybe an
additional
position to uh
want to inquire about uh the criminal
well the school board i suppose is
certainly entitled to but
the statute makes it clear that it is
the superintendent that has that
decision-making authority
the school board will write the policy
pursuant to to the statute but is this
it my understanding and reading the law
is it is the superintendent who makes
that ultimate determination and
recognize that superintendents do that
decision making as it pertains to hiring
choices and background checks
constantly and in fact last session a
bill was passed to allow
superintendents i believe it might have
been a bill that rep mullen
sponsored a co-sponsor to allow that
responsibility to be designated to a
certain individual
because it was so overwhelming but i
think when we look at this we're looking
at it in isolation as a bus and a bus
driver but really the context is this is
a contractor
this is like any other contract service
whether it's janitorial services or
lunch services or bringing people in to
fix the roof services this is a
contractor and as such the sau would
conduct the background check they are
the governmental entity who would be in
receipt of the new hampshire record and
the fbi record
they would
review that record of that individual
pursuant to the section 5 violations and
then more importantly the district
policy to say is this person
appropriate to be uh serving in our
particular school okay great thank you
very much
my pleasure thank you are there any
other questions for attorney fenton
not seeing it thank you very much
we don't have any other pink cards on
not seeing anybody else to discuss that
will close his hearing
and open the next hearing in about 10
minutes
foreign
okay
i don't know if i can do that today i'm
tired
what's taste eight glenn
19.
okay there's
you're gonna have to run this because
i'm not gonna be here
so those go that way
and these
go that way okay
okay
do you have more cards for
12 36
okay
but
you got a couple minutes
remember that clock is accurate now
oh chase are you tired too
i'll tell you i'm like
dragging today of course i was up at
midnight
and then got up at five to get down here
but
this committee will get that
that's what i'm working towards my wife
wants to go to a quilt center out in
she gives them to kids to friends to
family
um
we have
i have two grandkids are living in
romania
right
and so she sent there were three of
those over there but you know to ship
something now to romania
it costs like 100 bucks just to get
a small package over there
and then when it gets there their laws
say that that you have to pay the
equivalent of what's in the package
it's
you know yeah
now i send ups and fedex you don't have
to do that it's a private company going
to pray to him
[Music]
i think it is time for our
next hearing
which is on house bill 1236
relative to the legislative oversight
committee for the education improvement
and assessment program
and i will call on the prime sponsor
representative ladd
thank you very much representative
cordelli and members of the education
committee for the record my name is rick
ladd
and i
represent the town of haverhill
this bill which we have before us today
hb 1236
is a repeal of the repeal
and let me explain where we are in that
uh if you were to look at the second
sheet down going in where there's a one
that's circled by a big circle at the
top with my
um
my
penmanship at the top which i don't want
to brag about i shouldn't
uh this is a a bill that came in
each year
that we have sessions or each time each
biennium there's always a large bill
that comes in because this legislature
be it if you're
a republican or a democrat
we're all anxious to eliminate
legislation
that's outdated no longer has the use
it's oftentimes relative to commissions
committees boards task force etc
there
we have so many going on
it's hard to find people to serve on
these particular commissions and
committees task force councils boards
etc
so we go through the process
of finding those particular areas of
statute
which need to be purged or deleted from
statute you can see in this particular
year
there's a number and i this is a this a
this uh bill that the first one you see
here this hb 1245 back in uh 2020
had 12 pages to it
one of the bills if you go to this the
back page that first one where it says
page 2
and i didn't give you the other 10 pages
you can see that rsa 193 c colon 7 and
rs
rsa 193
c current 8
were repealed
now
that statutory language
is language pertaining to
the statewide education improvement and
assessment oversight committee which has
the responsibility of overseeing our
performance program our improvement and
assessment program our statewide
improvement program our statewide
assessment program of which we haven't
changed that statutory language
for several years
so
naturally that committee has not been
active
but the need for that particular
legislation still exists
you can go to the very back page in this
and you can see a sheet that i or some
correspondence i just recently received
this fall
from
the representative from conway
who is on finance division two at that
time and she was tasked this year
to look at all at the bottom of the page
there you can see statutory language
referencing the advisory council of the
education of children who had who are
deaf or hard of hearing and on it goes
down that list those are bills they were
saying hey should we re
repeal these bills should we repeal
these areas of statute
and of course we went down and look i
looked at that and i also mentioned that
several legislators wait there's some
things here that are very useful that we
are still using
and maybe it's not been reflected as far
as are used for example the
uh if you were looking right there at
the advanced manufacturing and education
advisory council or the
um
going on down to uh issues that are
the task force on the math learning
community program that's a program which
we had with the community college system
in new hampshire dealing with that
dorian and it's we had 36 schools
involved with it at the time where the
last two years while they're in high
school kids are getting a program that's
more aligned to their learning teaching
styles
and for children that had difficult time
at the end of sophomore year they were
put in these programs and they're coming
out better prepared for community
college as a result of having this
program that beth had coordinated out of
nhti et cetera
there's other areas there that you can
see too that were on that list the home
education advisory council and we know
that
the the person one of the persons was on
that was barbara shaw
and that was she saw that as we can't
give that up right now we need to have
that continue
and i wrote back to karen you can see
the top of that page that
i will get back to you on the commission
committees mentioned below we need to be
careful on this for example a number of
rsas were identified on an omnibus bill
back in 2020 which you have before you
and it repealed rsa 193 cn 8 7 and 8.
that's turned into a disaster as this
legislation was related to the new
hampshire statewide education
improvement and assessment oversight
committee the oversight committee is key
to adequacy review and needed whenever
doe opts to modify or change academic
standard rules
the commissioner and i reference this
statute when rewriting adequacy content
following the governor's veto message
for 242 242 as you recall was the veto
message dealing with adequate educa
content of inadequate education
it had a lot more to it but it did
regarding the costing of an adequate
education
but it did reference this particular
improvement assessment oversight
committee
but
we didn't know because it hadn't gone
into statute books that had already been
repealed
so if we had enacted 242 there's
reference in 242 to this committee that
doesn't exist
going on further
it was quite a shock other words so we
need to be careful i'll get back to and
after completing some work on the 14
identified rsas below for example the
task force on math learning communities
is key to the 11th and 12th grade math
courses designed to teach matt to those
students who have been identified as
needing remedial support upon entering
the community college system as you may
recall the representative dan wolf was
very involved with this program along
with myself working with beth and it's
shown remarkable gains the policy
committee designed the program with nhti
it goes on to say that so
my response was let me look through this
and i did look through it and there's
some areas that definitely notified him
don't mess with it uh even though it may
not have been addressed in the last year
certainly covet has put a lot of breaks
on what we do in terms of subcommittee
work committee work commission work etc
so going back to the the you saw number
one there but number two
last night
i was looking at the statutes just
something i love to do at midnight
but and it was midnight
um i looked in 193 h colon 2
which is a current statute
you can find it in the book
it references what the legislative
oversight improvement and
committee a committee on on on standards
et cetera
so
the we we even though we evolve and of
course if you go to number p the circle
number three
it tells you
what the responsibilities and duties of
this committee is
it's been very helpful for us in the
past
and when we went to write 242 or the
remake of 242
we had automatically put that in and
then we come whoops we can't do that
there's no way of getting this
accountability back in
and certainly the legislature when we're
talking about the statewide assessment
should be involved
in what we're going to use whether it's
going to be smarter balanced
or some other instrument that we use
that's what we have that oversight over
without that committee we don't have it
we don't have it
it was a mistake i'm sure if when it was
put forward in 2020
if
everybody was aware what was going on
we would probably say put the brakes on
it
we need to have that available as a tool
for this particular committee here and
um
i think that you you can see the what
i've
rest of it which i put in there
i i put a copy of 242 in there just so
you would see on the last page on hb 242
that's room that's the four the
attachment with a four on it
if you went to the fourth page
and this is what we acted on when on the
veto day it said right within that bill
the commissioner shall provide the
legislative oversight committee
identified in rsa 193 c clone 2 with an
annual status report by november 1.
if there's no committee anymore there
won't be that report that we receive
so
it's my
opinion
that we really need to have this put
back in the law i've talked with the
folks across at lsr and they they see it
too
i would suggest that
that's the primary intent for doing this
it's nothing was done
to get rid of something uh and do it and
do any harm to our legislative process
one of those things when we have these
large omnibus bills
without the time to really do our
homework and our work
things happen
and that's what happened i'm sure it's
happened from both parties in the past i
know it has
and so i'm i'm requesting through this
legislation that we repeal that repeal
get it back in the book so we can have
this oversight that we so dearly cherish
here in the legislature thank you very
much
thank you i'll be glad to ask any
questions if there are any yes
representative porter
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question uh representative
vlad do you know how often
this
uh commission legislative oversight
committee was meeting were they meeting
on a regular basis or was it is that one
of the reasons why they hadn't been
meeting and that's why it was felt that
it maybe
had
outlived its usage
i think that if if we go back
i know the the one of the last times we
had a lot of discussion on it is when we
we left uh when we
looked at
esser
the uh and that was about what two or
three years ago
there was a lot of discussion regarding
the oversight and how we and we utilized
at that time a great deal
but since then when we have not gone
forward with changing any kind of
federal legislation regard to
the the law esser
we we haven't addressed that
you can see that i had a need to use it
when we did 242
and uh and i think that we will all have
a need when we start talking about the
content of an adequate education and
secondly when we get into the
accountability and the oversight of how
we account how we measure growth and all
that that will come right back here and
it's good to have a group such as this
that can
get into the let's say the weeds on on
some of these assessments
and and and try to bring forward i know
that's when we came out with the
recommendation that statewide
achievement shouldn't be just
achievement it should be also looking at
growth
so that's one of the positive things
that came out of it represented
follow-up
until i'm tired i just lost my question
so
if how often would this
be meeting
i mean how long are the terms of the
people who are on this i guess i'm
looking at who's on the committee
and
we've got
members of the house and members of the
senate is it a two-year term
is it a is it a ongoing
with no ends in sight or
how does it's just
how long are the terms
it's the chairman of the house education
committee
for example
uh i would be the chair of it this year
it does switch like many of the
committee stuff between the senate and
the house
for the bienniums
um
prior to that would have been
represented milor prior to that would
have been myself for several bienniums
and then represent guile they've all
conducted these meetings
it's based on need and and there's no
sense in having a commission meeting
just for the sense of having a
commission meeting
but if you're going to change where
you're going with improvement and
assessment this is where this really
engages it's just like our higher
education committee which we have
that's going to be a very active
committee now when we're talking merger
we're talking four-year degrees and all
this other stuff at the community
college level that's going to kick in
and have to work with us
so uh i i feel that it's
when we are looking for it i think
represent umber was correct and
contacting me before
um she made this decision well we'll
just slice this slice and dice it she
said
what's the purpose what's the intent
etc so one thing one more okay thank you
so i'm looking at the membership and and
i don't mean to cause any
waves or anything but i'm wondering if
there's some opportunity for both the
majority party and the minority party to
appoint people
onto this
oversight committee because as it stands
now it could be all
the majority
if that's how the majority wanted it i
know in the past there were efforts made
to make sure that
yeah i i have no object i i think the
whole purpose of it is i think there's
people here all all around this room
which if they had the time
because we could be in a year where we
needed that to really engage in what
we're doing but it's um
i would look first for
the understanding that people have about
improvement assessment and i'd take i
would i would hope you're correct i have
no it's not a party thing this is all
the kids in the state this is how we
measure our performance as a state in
terms of achievement that we talk about
all the time here we've talked about it
today
but we do have different viewpoints on
certain items and it might well that's
fine
that's part of a few points that's part
of our society now we have life if we
all thought the same i think we'd be
represent tina
thank you mr chair this is uh probably a
teachable moment for me
for you to give give me this information
but
uh one of the things i've had difficulty
finding is the reports that are supposed
to be given
to the education committee
since i've been
on the education committee this is my
third term
i have not
officially received a report
from any any kind of working
group whether it's legislative overs
well the legislative oversight
committees
usually in in the law state that the
report is available to the education
committee and
uh i thought it would be handed out but
you know i'm willing to go and search
for it too but
i'd would like to know where these
reports
are have been published in the past and
and how they're distributed yeah
i think dissemination of materials is
very important it's just like i have a
couple reports in there on the desk
right now and i handed you know i
mentioned it the other day the bullying
report and the other one
that's all information that everybody
should have a chance to see and read
the higher education committee has been
meeting and
that's resulted in
a bill that we have coming forward
before us which is the bill dealing with
the
uh merger of granite state and and uh
unh
we've had other uh groups that have
meeting like the council for uh career
technical education we have folks here
on this committee that are part of that
there again the recommendations are
coming forward in legislation
the minutes of the meetings
are provided and put into that folder
but they're not disseminated
outwards uh
for for one thing we have so many
commissions and committees um
i i believe that uh it would be wise for
us to try and get that information out
somehow to those that are interested in
receiving this material
definitely to the
folks which are in leadership on the
committee be at the
myself or be at the ranking uh person in
the minority whatever given year that is
we have had this issue for uh for a long
time i can remember when uh i first came
on here we i didn't know these things
existed
um
and i didn't know
i hadn't read all the statutes i guess
or the rules but uh i i i would support
what you're saying represent tanner
there's got to be a better way of
getting this information out
some of it's extremely important um
and
there has been question where for
example we even need a higher education
committee
i think it's that rotates between the
senate and the house i think if you look
back the years
that we have been most effective
are the years
we have house leadership
in those committees and commissions
nothing against the senate but if we put
down any committee or commission that
was developing and we put down three
senators it'll come back one
and would be lucky to get one uh
we'll get all our representatives and
they will be working on it that's
happened on the
group we had for tuition transportation
cte for the first several sessions it
was just reps there at the table
until the others were appointed
so
i think there's a genuine reason why we
need these i i if we don't have them
we're losing our oversight of where
we're going with legislation now and
into the future and i i just
put the red flag up as a caution be
careful
any further questions from the committee
representative mullen
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question representative ladd i
um
when i read this bill i
obviously looked at all of the duties of
this committee
and my question to you is um
who is doing all of the work that this
committee
had been doing prior to this being
repealed
or is
is it not being done
there has not been any oversight since
this was
done away with back what 2020.
prior to that so you'll see some of the
changes which are occurring in statute
happening in 2017. that's right about
the time that the assert came out and we
we dug in and did some work and that
committee was very involved with it
um
we've also been involved in years with
this oversight when we went into common
core if you recall way back
to send our waiver our application in
they had to get approval from that
committee
which i believe it came out like a 4-3
vote to go ahead and submit
and that was back when we had virginia
berry as commissioner
and paul leather as the deputy he sat at
that meeting
that was a good meeting i can remember
it
and we were moving in a good direction
it's going to be just as good as what we
if we sit back and do nothing and we're
going to get whatever comes at us
thank you you're welcome
any further questions uh seeing none
thank you very much thank you very much
and uh next we have dr green from the
department
good afternoon nate green from
department of education and i'm happy to
answer any questions that the committee
representative mullen
thank you mr chair and welcome back dr
greene
um i guess i'm going to ask you the
question that i just asked
representative ladd
there is a ton of oversight designated
to this committee with regards to
academic standards and pupil
identification and uh statewide
performance targets
who's been doing the work um
or what is your understanding dr green
of who's been doing the work in the
absence of the legislative oversight
committee
sure so we have a pretty comprehensive
system that includes both department and
state employees as well as contractors
that do a lot of work on our
accountability and assessment system
but when we talk about oversight you
know as something that is oversight of
the work itself um we have an
accountability state task force uh
there's about 30
it's mostly made up of superintendents
principals
some of the department representatives
and some teachers it's a group that was
recently reformed
they had done some similar work as uh
chairman ladd had talked about back in
2017 when we were moving from no child
left behind to essa and so they had i
think they hadn't met for about two
years and then about eight months ago we
started meeting with that group as again
and they reformed because as you said
there's a lot of work that does need to
go on and we felt like we wanted some of
that oversight to come from the field as
well
representative tanner
thank you mr taran thank you dr green so
that group is reformed that you've just
been talking about
where can we find out the information
about
who's on the group
if they are issuing reports in minutes
of the of the meetings
i can provide that to the house
education committee um it's something
that we can uh probably post on our
website as well
we've had one official meeting of the
group the next meeting of the group is
yes so
so um
can can other reports be be on that
website as well from different uh
oversight groups or
focus groups that that that you have i
mean i just
the rules
wanting to to have access to that and i
i just feel like i i need to have more
access to some of this this information
absolutely i don't see why not okay
any further questions
i think uh
that's the
end of the people who want to testify
so i will close the hearing on house
bill 1236 in a few minutes we'll start
and now that we're out of hearing i just
want to add something as
luck would have it i happen to have
lunch today with
karen evil who had just come from
legislative administration where they're
trying to revive the committee on
committees to look at abolishing on
these committees and she said that it
passed last session and it died in
committee of conference coming from the
senate the chair and current house
wouldn't agree to so they're trying all
over again so just this morning at 11 45
legislative administration heard the
bill on re-establishing the committee on
committees to start abolishing things
all over again i just thought you guys
might find that interesting that this is
all going on at the same time today
it's just amazing that you know here we
have oversight even on the state board
and delivering their new rules to us
we've given that up by eliminating this
particular group
it's information that we need
and we should really pursue it
uh but i i agree with you
they're they're all looking at it
doesn't matter which party they always
do this and that's their job
you can't talk with these things
all wet
um
see that's not not if you've got that
type of leadership see
that's the problem
you would think that what's going on in
higher ed right now
that the higher education committee
would be meeting right they only met
because i went to ruth and said you know
you're chair of this thing oh really
and and uh what's going on
well you know we've been talking merger
about both systems now we're trying to
merge with that pretty critical time
we're doing this and
what's happening is we're having to
start doing this with subcommittee work
and or like we did remember the group we
got together and we looked at the 30 or
40 type questions regarding the larger
merger
and we said slow down no that worked out
well i thought the public higher
education study commission committing
work well two years ago
and we were very fortunate though
because division two had asked for that
report
now
and see there there's
one i agree i wouldn't rotate it between
the center no no no i can't keep it yeah
and you know what you said it's probably
going to be just that you know
thursday would be like four after we're
done
okay yeah yeah and mel can stay flexible
but we just wanted to talk about what we
talked about okay
which is let's see if we can come
here is yeah he can actually go through
um
bills and put a report together and
stuff like that too
i was you know
you i had you make the motion on the
granite state yeah i've got the board oh
you got it done because i don't know
dave if you haven't i could just give
you one and see what you're thinking
there
then uh
i'm i'm happy
okay because i got i got a little cheat
because and we don't have to make that
very long yeah no no no three three
three sentences three or four cents max
great you send me three and i'll add one
more
yeah
see
i i think these oversight yeah a lot of
times they don't meet
and
and we're losing something but if we're
really serious about doing our work here
yeah i hear a lot of good questions in
these hearings
that
wow wouldn't it be great if we could
have another group that we wouldn't have
to always be putting together a subgroup
direct them there and
and and what's the agenda that's put
together on these the on these oversight
committees they don't know what's going
on
so then we have folks
that are making decisions we could have
superintendents making all these
decisions
yeah which
it's not the way we operate
yeah so yeah okay so tomorrow yeah
[Music]
we've got a good group of people to
testify
okay i'll go upstairs because i want to
abstract random
yeah one six two two for me
yeah yeah 16 22. upstairs okay
you ready for a route
yeah you can go ahead i'm just going to
run upstairs get my john henry in on it
okay
okay i think we're uh just about ready
for uh our next bill
which is
house bill 1639 relative to the youth
risk behavior survey in schools and i
will call on the prime sponsor
representative boehm
thank you mr chairman and
members of the education committee for
the record i am ralph fome hillsborough
district 20. i have 10 on the thing
because
that's the new new district going to be
in and i couldn't remember which one i
was on
which district anyway from town
listfield
youth risk behavior survey
some years ago
some of you were here i introduced the
bill to put a rein in on non-academic
surveys
parents had to be notified and questions
provided
first bill was for opt-out it was later
changed to opt-in
bill finally passed and is now law even
though have been multiple tries to
change it over the years
argument is that schools in some cases
get money for doing the surveys
selling student information for monday
for money i guess is okay for some
however the youth risk behavior survey
was left in this survey is taken by the
joke by most high school students
when i was on the school board this was
given in our high school i heard from my
spies
that the student which was students that
the students were taking this as a class
project
for example how many times do we get
drunk
mary does your boyfriend hit you
uh do you take drugs
some weeks later our principal came to
our school board meeting with the
disastrous results
i then informed him how the survey was
taken the student school board member we
have two on our school board student
verified this
other schools have the same issues when
students know the survey is being taken
social media goes rampant with entries
on how to answer the questions
also parents need to know how what their
children are being asked
parental rights
all questions on any survey must be
given to parents so they can make the
decision to allow their child to take
the survey over the years we've heard
arguments that parents do not get the
permission slip for the survey so they
do not opt in
interesting parents have to give an
opt-in for field trips those seem to be
returned
parents don't opt in because they want
the child to take it
now also nowadays this can also be done
electronically emails etc to the parents
also sexual questions how many high
school students will answer that they
are not sexually active
do any remember when you went to high
school
these surveys are a joke and high school
treat high school students treat them as
such
answers over time have changed for
example when i went to high school if
you asked students if they were sexually
active of course 90 of the boys would
say yes and only 10 of the girls were
saying yes now probably now 90 percent
say yes and which are still all lies
now somebody testified to testify that
the survey and others are all academic
it is the school's responsibility to
teach and not be social workers
these surveys only interfere with the
student learning activities for example
in the cte committee that i'm on it came
out the sub cte students may miss their
cta cte courses because this survey is
taken at their sending school
it's been proven time after time that no
survey is anonymous and at what
percentage does it make the server
immaterial if only some are answered
correctly
remember the survey is done by the cdc
and depending on what administration is
in power questions do become political
in the past there were questions on guns
at home
now i bet there will be questions on
vaccinations
another argument is that need that they
need the entire school to take the
survey to get the full result what
difference students answering as a joke
or not answering at all and thank you
uh thank you representative are there
uh seeing none just one last point i do
did find a an error on line 12 which
i'll get fixed thank you
thank you very much representative
next
good afternoon mr chairman members of
the committee
for the record my name is david
goldstein i'm the chief of police in the
city of franklin
and i'm here on behalf of the new
hampshire associations of chiefs of
police
and we object
to the um bill as written
and quite simply we object to the
portion that's opt in
we would prefer to leave it as opt-out
and the example that i had relative to
that is a student's backpack how many
parents actually get to know what kind
of paperwork's in there
i've been a police officer for over 42
years
and i've been a police chief for over 18
uh and in light of this particular
committee i'll share a little bit of my
background and as to why
we have an interest in this particular
bill
i have a bachelor's degree in psychology
a master's degree in public health and a
phd
in counseling and human services and i
am working on a second phd in psychology
and sociology at present
oh and by the way mr chairman just for
future reference the configuration of
the flags is incorrect
in franklin we depend on the
youth behavior the yrbs
approximately 13 years ago we applied
for a multi-million dollar grant
to study youth behavior relative to drug
abuse
and from a public health point of view
we wanted to look at it from a primary
prevention point of view as opposed to
rehabilitation and treatment we wanted
prevention
the yrbs gave us a great deal of
information that we were able to use in
applying for a multi-million dollar
grant that is still in effect today and
we certainly uh are appreciative of the
fact as in any survey research the
difficulties that one runs into with
questionnaires but there really is no
other way to get this information
the comments of the previous speaker are
taken uh certainly with a grain of salt
uh because i'm unaware personally of any
of the facts and circumstances that
underlie his arguments the uh the
resources that he relied on for those
certainly children will be children
students will be students we understand
all of that but again we do get some
legitimate uh
results from the yrbs
so with that
again we would only ask that it be an
opt-in excuse me opt-out as opposed to
an opt-in and i'm happy to answer any
questions the committee might have thank
you very much chief are there any
questions from the committee
yes representative mullen
thank you mr chair and thank you for
coming to meet with us today
would you say that your work with youth
in the city of franklin is
affected by the information that you get
from the youth risk behavior survey
absolutely uh what we do
uh is we work directly with all of the
schools in the city uh while the yrbs is
primarily high school as you all know
for a while we were able to do middle
school as well but it became untenable
to be able to do that but yes the short
answer to your question is it does help
us with the teachers and with the
students and trying to develop these
programs specifically in our case for
primary prevention on drug abuse
further questions representative porter
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um can you answer for
me
are the results of these um surveys
confidential
yes from our point of view they
absolutely are and i've seen nothing in
my school system and i am very close
with our superintendent and the school
board i've seen nothing to suggest
otherwise
follow up so after the survey is taken
are they taken on the computer are they
taking paper and pencil and when they're
done what happens with that material
that i don't know because we don't get
involved in that part that's strictly
empty
thank you
uh
you've got the various levels of
expertise uncommon perhaps in the
average person in your position
as such i think would you be able to
give us
suggestions i guess is the right word um
for how we might improve the testing so
that we don't get
capricious
unserious answers
and such in other words how do you turn
it into a valid survey in your opinion
well again i don't think it's invalid at
this point so i would suggest that we
continue with it make it better make it
better certainly uh well again i i'm i
guess i'm old-fashioned i i've been
around an awful long time uh and i still
believe that students and teachers have
a very
special and strong bond and i believe
the teachers become teachers in order to
make to do that and to work with their
students and to help them and i think
that's the most important thing right
there is to keep that bond as strong as
it can be for as long as it can be and
then we'll get the legitimate results
from our students because they'll trust
their teachers there's no reason not to
trust a teacher at least in my opinion
uh other than that certainly we can
continue to look at the the application
of the survey itself how it's done if
it's done properly again the question
about computer versus paper and pencil
any of that stuff certainly we can we
can look at that but i think it's a very
valid study right now in public health
which this essentially is
in public health research these are the
types of questions we have to ask if we
want to know what's going on
do we want not do we want to put blood
turn a blind eye to some of these
questions yes sexual behavior amongst
adolescents is kind of embarrassing for
everybody but that way we can address
issues that children might have drug
abuse from our point of view is
incredibly important because we've lost
a generation
to drug abuse
and i challenge anybody to tell me we
have not because i see it on a daily
basis
and my officers see it and the rest of
my colleagues in the states see and
we're just a small state so certainly
i think that we just maintain and we
continue forward
there are other studies in history the
framingham study on cardiac issues
is ongoing it's a it's a longitudinal
study it's been going on for decades in
order to follow some of these things we
need to have this kind of information so
certainly i guess to try to answer your
question
in short form is keep the relationship
going and that's the best thing we can
do in my humble opinion follow-up yes
could i i ask you further then what
correlations are made that you can
quantify like behavioral incidents
of one sort or another sexual aggression
by any kind of violence anything that
you might
link with this in some way is that link
made and is it used in the analysis of
how you do things yes particular school
uh it can be and again i'm going to use
our example of drug use or drug abuse
and we see this and now we know what we
want what who we want to aim our efforts
at let's say what group what age group
what socio-economic group what have you
certainly we see that uh and again
working in conjunction with the school
board with the teachers with the
counselors with the social workers etc
in the school system uh so we can do
that uh you can take all this
information you can apply any statistics
you want to it for analysis try to
correlate you know
any kind of correlational statistics and
certainly we can come up with something
uh but in our case i i can speak best to
the drug issues
thank you very much you're more than
welcome thank you very much are there
further questions representative tanner
thank you mr chair and and thank you so
much chief for coming today
um anecdotally
have you
seen anything that leads you to believe
that this uh survey is so skewed by
people just not taking it seriously
kids not taking it seriously
i can say no and i have not
yet in my
13 years with franklin police department
i have not heard that from anybody in
the administration of the schools
further questions
i i've seen you in the hall for years
and years and years welcome thank you uh
have you had the opportunity to work
with the department i know you've
represented your association
um
have you had the opportunity to work
with doe in terms of the type and nature
of questions which are asked on a youth
risk behavior survey put out by the cdc
the department has an opportunity to
either put questions in or not
has your has law enforcement
been ever asked to
you know or suggest
issues that need address within that
survey um
to a large degree no i think what's
happened with law enforcement is we've
accepted the survey as it is and allowed
the experts at cdc to design and develop
the questionnaires and the questions
themselves uh some years ago i did meet
with the commissioner commissioner and
discussed some of this with him in a
very uh cursory way we i had some
questions for him about this as well as
other issues but other than that quite
frankly no but i'm certain that we would
be happy to do so if we were invited to
do so thank you for the questions from
the chief thank you very much for coming
today thank you my pleasure
petoskey you have written testimony as
well
sure um
good afternoon thank you for the
opportunity to testify my name is
rebecca boykovsky and i'm the kids count
policy coordinator at new futures i'm
here today on behalf of kids count and
also our children's behavioral health
coordinator emma savini who cannot be
here right now
new future new features appreciates the
opportunity to provide testimony and
opposition to house bill 1639 relative
to the youth risk behavior survey in
schools new futures is a nonpartisan
nonprofit organization that advocates
educates and collaborates to improve the
health and wellness of granite staters
we are dedicated to supporting and
strengthening a comprehensive and
integrated system of care for children
and youth location officials use this
anonymous data to track trends and
develop health systems and policies that
prevent and address risky and unhealthy
behavior by high school students
particularly in the age of covid it is
important to recognize any changes in
health behavior patterns in students so
that schools parents and programs can
adjust their strategies to support youth
accordingly the yrbs is purposefully
structured as an opt out program in
order to maximize participation and
expand data collection as widely as
possible to capture trends among
different population sets
this was a recognition of the importance
of gathering certain data in our schools
and the fact that surveys that require
active consent often end up with
insufficient sample sized biased samples
and unrepresented unrepresentation from
under representation from individuals
who are experiencing family stress due
to poverty substance use violence and
cultural differences
by removing this exemption and shifting
yrbs from opt out to opt-in this bill
will negatively impact data collection
and reduce the effectiveness of youth
safety and wellness programs in new
hampshire these programs require data
collection at a local level to track
student success
identify issues or system gaps and
comply with mandatory requirements from
federal funders
new futures unquestionably understands
the desire to protect students through
the active involvement of parents and
guardians under the statute in its
current form parents are still informed
of when a survey is conducted in their
child's school they are given access to
survey materials and they are allowed to
opt their child out of participation
either in writing or electronically the
statute as it's currently written
strikes the proper balance between
parental interest and the state's
interest in tracking data and should not
be changed through house bill 1639
it would be irresponsible to severely
limit data collection at a time where
the health and safety of new hampshire's
youth is so fragile
for these reasons presented new futures
strongly urges the committee to vote
house bill 1639 and expediate to
legislate and i will make a note that we
had many of our prevention partners and
providers sign on online that cannot be
here today so through my testimony i
also represent their opposition to this
bill as well and i'm happy to take any
questions if there are any
thank you very much are there any
questions
represent moffat
famous chair and thank you for being
here and for taking my question
so as i look at this this proposed
measure there's three i see three things
that the uh
that the prime sports is looking to have
happen he adds the word race is a list
of
factors at the bottom
he also says that the local school
district should approve the yrbs survey
and then the third thing is uh opt in
rather than opt out
so those are the three
components of the three changes that i
see here so
i know you're in opposition to this
so which of those components all three
of them are where
you're opposed to all three of them in
particular um changing um it to an
opt-in instead of an opt-out but at new
futures we support the yrbs as it is how
the
public health works with the cdc to have
specific questions on the yrbs so to
that extent we oppose any changes to the
current statute
okay thank you
are there further questions
miss chala from
dhhj
you you've marked on 10 minutes can you
just try to
squeeze a little tighter than that
idea chairman a member of the commission
can you hear me okay could you move the
oh sorry
my name is jacque chawla i'm the bureau
cheerful public health statistic and
informatics at the division of public
health services
i'm here today in opposition to
hospital 1639 and act
relative to the youth risk behavior
survey in schools
the use risk behavior survey ybs is a
standardized voluntary survey designed
to monitor
resilience and health behavior that
contribute to the leading of cause of
death disability and social problems
among youth and adults
new hampshire has conducted ybs since
1993 and has consistently promoted the
opportunity for parent review
the survey has been designed to protect
the privacy of those participating but
regardless of reason
parents have the opportunity to up their
children out of participation
for new hampshire statue school district
must notify parents of a non-academic
survey of questionnaires and its purpose
public health makes the ybs
questionnaire available unless one month
before the first school contacts the
survey
the questionnaires is also published on
dhhs webpage
parents or guardians have the
opportunity to review the questions
and or discuss with their children
prior to the survey
school district and school boards have
the freedom to vote for participation
and to take up in or up out approach
since yrbs is voluntary students can
drop out or decide not to participate
anytime during the survey
students may skip any questions they do
not wish to answer
and students may stop taking the survey
at any point without penalty
schools may also decline to participate
at any time
even after the survey is conducted
new hampshire uses passive parental
permission to early mr williams the
proposed legislation legislation will
require ybs to use active parental
permission which is up in
active opting in requires more time and
resources from both state and schools
and will likely reduce the number of
students who participate in the survey
following up with parents related to
upping permission forms
will be time consuming and will cause
additional burden to the survey process
it is anticipated that up in requirement
would create a significant barrier to
the collection of meaningful
data about user risk behavior
public health anticipates the response
rate
will decrease without being requirement
low response rate
on surveys makes data less reliable and
less variable and if the response rate
goes below 60
the survey will not be representative of
the new hampshire high school student
population
other states that
have required active parental permission
have been unable to meet this
requirement for student participation
and have since been unable to gather
important data to guide public health
policy and schools and community
community prevention programs
as a result of the opening requirement
will create a situation
in which new hampshire communities and
schools may have no state specific data
available
given the emphasis that new hampshire
has placed on eliminating and preventing
risk behavior such as vaping
drinking violence suicide bullying and
harassment and more
it is
imperative that we should not hinder our
efforts by placing unnecessary barriers
in the way of meaningful data collection
the school district
may not have the ybs data excuse me the
school district by not having ibs data
may not have a sufficient resource that
could support students and districts
with identified needs related to
behavior health or substance use
disorders
programs assisting with students at risk
of early substance use disorder
could help prevent the occurrence of
long-term chronic disease
implications that are
detrimental to the individual and could
have implications
for new hampshire medicaid resources
as region rsa 186 11 90 protects and
from
promote
parent participation
parents have access to the information
they need to make informed decisions
and schools have the tools and
information they need to create data
inform the curriculum and prevention
programming
by adding unnecessary barriers which is
up being requirement to participation
new hampshire will lose the data we need
to develop policy that protects use
in order to preserve
access to important information that is
representative of the needs strength and
risk to new hampshire youth dhhs opposes
the change described in hospital
1639 thank you very much
are there questions of the speaker yes
representative cordelli
thank you mr chairman thank you for
being here today
one question one of the key items with
the proposed legislation
is an opt-in
participation for
based on your testimony it looks like
school boards have the freedom to vote
for either
an opt-in survey or an opt-out survey am
i
understanding that correctly yes so we
the current practice that we are taking
is up out so we don't at school to say
you need to open or into about we give
the school board to decide whether they
want to participate wire bs or they want
to take upping of our option we did have
a school in the past chose up in
approach and the state of public health
provided up in templates for them to be
able to communicate it with parents
but in the next survey cycle that
particular school chose up out option
because they didn't get enough students
or enough are being formed to be able to
follow if i could yes go ahead thank you
um
so um
there was just one school to your
knowledge that shows an opt-in
participation
and they
do you
do all schools know that you have
provided
for an opt-in
based on a school board vote yes
we provide training ahead of the survey
started to the school element traders
and just because of covert this year the
training program that we provide is like
online uh documents that we posted
online for school administrators to be
able to look at the slides and take
questions and then communicate with us
how they would like to administer the
survey in their schools so we do have
upping templates as well as upload
template provide to the schools if they
require
thank you thank you
thank you very much our representative
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
in your experience
or the experience of the department uh
do you find that the schools find this
information valuable
yes we do have schools um
they find the information very very
valuable so we provide a community level
report to school districts to
superintendents directly
so for community level report we do not
release to anyone except superintendent
and if if someone else would like to
request the specific community levels
uh report we will need to get a consent
from superintendent so that we can read
this to that particular individual who
requested a survey
result
so some schools they also posted their
community level uh report on their own
website um you know in my knowledge that
you um share the information with their
own communities
and schools as far as i know and also in
my knowledge that has some grand
requirement and they utilize the ybs
result to
for their
prevention or for their curriculum etc
so yes to your question
schools find the
yrbs data is valuable yes
further questions
yes represent litchfield thank you
if i may i have two questions the the
first question is
would it be fair to say that we're kind
of making a large assumption here that
this information is being disseminated
to the school board whether or not they
have the option
um to even have this survey or whether
or not it's opt-in or opt-out
and would it be fair to say that it's a
very large assumption to make at this
point in time that parents are just
choosing not to respond versus they
really don't want their children taking
this survey
so for the first question
if i understand your question correctly
the vote for some schools excuse me i
should say that for some schools in my
knowledge that they
work with the school board to vote
whether they want to have a yrbs this
year or not
and then if they vote to
participate yrbs then they will let us
know that they know whether they would
like to take upping opt-out
approach did i answer your question if i
didn't get it right
you did i i can tell you've been on
school boards 15 years now and not once
have i ever been asked that question
though
okay
may i follow up with a second question
okay um
my second question is
is the fact that we are being told that
this information is being kept
confidential um we have a wide range of
size in schools throughout this state
which would lead me to believe that
there could be privacy issues for
example
how confidential is this if
so far i'm hearing the results are being
given to the superintendent the police
department the department of health and
human services and being posted on the
school website
those are not the survey itself those
are the aggregated data
the report that we collected from the
survey result we aggregated and then do
the
time trend chart or by gender
on this kind of graphic information
versus report to the school
so it's not a survey itself it's not the
record level
that students um
answered for each question no we don't
realize that at all
thank you
for the question representative porter
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um do you know in the
schools that are doing the opt out
what percentage
of families are opt out
do you know the average of an opt-out
this product information is not um
communicated with the state so we give
the schools on
for their own to
work on the upping up doubt on we do not
know
the percentage or the number of the
upping of about in the particular school
i i have a question for you
i'm curious to know if the results of
the survey
are made available in other words
certain groups are getting ahold of this
information
but are the results for a particular
school or school district posted on
their website so that
all can see where we're going in terms
of any particular question if you know
track it back over the years
so for the uh data dissemination yrbs
has two portions the first portion is
the sample size which is
for each score or for each area we pick
the samples and then the samples doesn't
mean doesn't represent a specific score
the sample size is about maybe
on top of my head like one third of the
total high school population we send it
to cdc
with no school in um
information with no class information in
yet then cdc will connect with other
states together and then post make the
data analysis and make the results
available to look at the key point key
indicator for example the percentage of
students
who reported or who answered
they they were asian
these type of questions available on the
cdc website the community level report
that i mentioned to the superintendent
specifically
is the
information for each individual question
for the specific
survey year for each individual question
to that school only we also put the
state level data as well as the region
level data as a comparison for
superintendent to understand
how the school performed or after the
survey result
analysis analyzed
how the school performed compared to
the state level or the region level
and that
that report is only
sent delivered to the superintendent and
it's up to school how they would like to
utilize their own specific community
level report do you know of any schools
in this state that are
posting the aggregated data for that
school or school district and posting it
on the web
as far as i know i think the bedford
bedford high school
one school
i i didn't look into all the schools
but bedford high schools um they they as
far as i know that they post their
community level report on their own
website
that's interesting thank you very much
representative tanner
thank you mr chair i was wondering if
you could
explain any kind of benefit that you
have seen come out of this survey as far
as perhaps programs that hhs has done or
grants that they've given or you know
some concrete you know why are we doing
this and what are the benefits for it
because it seems like we're more focused
on how it's being done
hi chairman lauden members of the
committee my name is abby rogers i'm the
legislative liaison for the division of
public health services i think i can
take that question um the the data
that's collected
by the yrbs is used to determine both
federal grants and grants to affect
substance use disorders um other mental
health treatments uh
to to combat vaping alcohol use as i
said substance use disorders so the data
used is uh better to inform uh
what is going on in the schools and then
you know of course that affects the
greater community and those grants are
given based on that data so they were
able to match the needs identified in
the data with the yrbs with with what's
going on in the school districts and
those grant funds are given and that's
why it's especially important not to
make the survey
an opt-in because we would lose that
data and potentially lose those federal
dollars to help school districts and the
communities
yes
um so that's that's from your standpoint
at the at the state government level
that you know it's grants kind of thing
and we heard from the police chief of
franklin about how it affects how they
are dealing and also grants that they
get locally
um
you know to to approach particularly the
drug problem but other problems as well
do you have any feedback from from
schools or maybe we have other people
that are going to come up and talk that
that i can also ask that question that
that the information has been
particularly helpful for their school
and that
that within their school district they
made a significant changes or involved
programs uh
that actually were a result of some of
the information from the
survey sure thank you for the question
would you have any specifics on that
answer more on your first questions
how data has been used so for example
like mapping data for youth we also
utilize in some legislative activities
to provide this kind of report in order
to support or to provide more detailed
information on the legislative
uh yes we were able to use some data
from the yrbs to better inform
legislators on the effect of raising the
tobacco purchasing age to 21 for example
we use that data in that instance and we
use it a lot with our
any legislation having to do with mental
health disorders and certainly substance
abuse and uh prevention treatments that
are necessary um i don't i'm not sure if
there is um someone representing the
schools here um for your second question
so i can't answer that question
specifically but thank you for the
question um
and i do have my own point of my own to
make i don't know if the committee has
any more questions before i get to that
yes i have a question and i think
represent cordelia may have one too
um i'm curious no so we have this the
results of the survey provided to the
superintendent and to
i would hope the school board as well
unless it's held by the superintendent
to help be helpful within the district
or school as has been just mentioned to
us
if it's not posted to the community how
is the community going to engage and be
partners
in addressing
some of the information that's been
identified on this survey without that
being posted um
and i have a second question but maybe
you can ask that answer that first one
first
yes i can answer the first question so
other than the customizer community
level report we also take data requests
to
do the data analysis on the specific
area
on the specific topics as well so for
communities who focused on maybe drug
misuse they they are interested in
certain questions in the certain areas
so in that way we are able to customize
as a table format or chart visualization
format to provide this information for
their own communities and with the
questions that they are interested
we aggregate more than three or four
schools together we do not provide the
individual schools a statistic analysis
to
the um to the data request so it's
always the area
community aggregation report that we
provide so other than the
excuse me other than the community level
report i will provide directly to
superintendents we also provide a
customized data analysis for the needed
area as well
so in a follow-up if i as a interested
community member
have not been informed
and unaware of the results of these
surveys
then how can i then ask for information
if i you know regarding specific areas
within that survey if i
i i don't know and or seen
the the results the survey it seems to
me that if we're going to have a
community involved
that we need to involve the community
and make people aware
that there may be this a particular
element or issue within our community
and so um i i feel that we do this every
year
and yet are we making progress i don't
know
i don't know because i've never seen the
data for my community
so is that available for example if if i
as chair
of this committee say okay i'd like to
have the results for every community in
this state submitted to this this body
would that be available to us
if you um well
first uh first i would like to answer
the first question is our internal
programs in the department as well as
the international partners they use our
report the statewide report as well as
public health reaching report that we
provided to the public health reaching
areas those reports awaited simple the
result so it doesn't have the specific
school
information and for public health region
network they are able to utilize the
report and then go to their own region
to do some prevention work and the
prevention work or the protection work
this is another
part of the public health business which
i personally do not involve that much
but back to your question chairman if
you're requesting the report for the um
all the community level data then the
first thing that i will need to do is to
contact all the superintendents to get
their consent in order to release the
however are we talking excuse me are we
talking aggregate data for that if you
have a district let's say of
a thousand kids
so it's not going to be pointing to a
specific child it's not a small district
with maybe 60 or 70 kids in it yes that
is under
in within one district so generally one
district may have only one high school
and with that information for school
level or community level it's not
weighted so we are not able to say this
school is performing better or worse
than the state we will say that the
number is higher or lower than state for
the request that i get your example we
will provide the aggregate result
in the public health region or close to
public health region that can provide
significance in the state are in in the
thank you
representative cordelia and then
representative cornell
uh thank you mr chairman uh thank you
for taking another question um
i am uh very curious about um the fact
that um it's up to the superintendent as
to the release of the community um
information um
i take it that that is a
policy of the department of uh health
and human services and i was wondering
since it's not in statute is is that a
rule
that um has been put forward by
by the uh by the department
there is no written policy or rule
in such a way that the community level
report only relates to superintendents
this is an agreement that when we
encourage your recruiter schools
a promise that we do not release you the
school data or community data
uh to other people unless
superintendents agree
to read this data to another party so
it's kind of like the agreement that we
have oral agreement if i may say
with the superintendents when we
encourage or recruit the schools to
participate this the survey
i would just think as a school board
member i'd be upset if the uh not
knowing that the data was available and
the superintendent wasn't
providing that information to us same
way with maybe an alderman in manchester
i'd be very
concerned if it was up to the
superintendent whether i saw that data
or not yes so we give schools
you know
the opportunity to perform the survey we
also give school
superintendent specifically that the
authority
if that's the correct word whether the
school should release data to the school
board or not i believe school board can
request
this the survey result from
superintendents
thank you
representative cornell thank you and
this is just information but the
department of education has all of this
information on their website the
the survey the the results the survey
questionnaire the 10-year trend analysis
demographic data
results with graphs
all that is on the department of
education website so
it's it's there for anyone to to find
okay and follow up to that information a
question is that available
on a community basis that's what we're
driving in i'm not i don't want to
aggregate for our state i don't want the
aggregate for the country i'm interested
in knowing what the aggregate is for a
particular region or school district
fourth particular school district know
that data is not available publicly
for community if the community level is
public health region
which has
14 regions in new hampshire that data is
available online
i'd like to just follow up with it's not
available publicly
is it available
it is available for community level data
or school district level level data yes
it is available per request and we do
have the data request process in order
to
review who can you know
what the purpose of requesting the data
this kind of process that in place in
our
routine general data request process
represent tanner
thank you mr chair uh just as a as a
point because teachable moment uh i also
looked up but i looked up on the hhs
website where the same information is
available as available on the
department of education site and i
looked up greater sullivan area which is
sullivan county the county i represent
which had all the information they also
have a north north country which i
assume is your area
or goes into your area that's all
available on um health and human
services website and publicly available
further questions representative porter
thank you mr chair
i'll try to make this brief is the
reason why
the spec
non-publicly available information
is non-public
to protect the privacy
of the
people who
part took of the survey or is there
another reason
the main reason is yes to protect the
privacy
for the individual school district
another reason is we do not want to
mislead the information or misguided
information how does school report or
community school community reports
should be used
only if parents may say that
school a
is better than school b we try not to
create this kind of confusion among the
community
reps nelson
thank you mr chair
thank you for taking my question do they
ever ask students
say when they're going out of high
school if they were honest
when they gave the answer say in the
sixth grade is there a follow-up where
they you know in high school they would
probably be more honest to tell you yeah
i was clowning around in the middle
school or something is there ever a
follow-up and that type of thing
we do not follow up with students
or the schools on how they do the survey
or how students answer the survey for
yrbs new hampshire country only contact
high school's level so which is grade 9
to 12.
we do get requested for some middle
school survey but currently for new
hampshire we are not conducting middle
school survey the follow-up work that we
are doing is to
talk to school administrators how we can
improve the
survey administration operation process
in order to provide better
communications for schools to be able to
communicate with parents
or with students or to look into the
questionnaire questions
to assist the student to better
understand the questions
themselves or yourself
thank you are there any further
questions yes representative mullen
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question so
in my own mind to help me simplify
things
every question that's on that youth
survey can be found either on the dhhs
website or the doe website and every
parent has the option to opt out if they
choose that is correct so questionnaires
um
for 2021 y ibs of a we have 106
questions
all the questions in the questionnaires
can be found in dhhs website we do have
a link and then we can provide um you
know to the member of the commenters um
if you like
yes thank you
represent cordelia do you have a
question yes one final um
process question i guess
um
the survey questions at what point
do they go to the department of
education for review and selection of
questions thank you for the question so
uh the
ylbs is a journey effort between dhhs
and department of education so every
time uh first of all ybs is every other
year so we survey on the odd year so
last time we survey is in 2021 next time
the survey will be performed as in 2023
so every time when we prepare the
questionnaires based on we will receive
the standard questions from question
sets from cdc those are the suggested
questions for those questions
we try to keep the questions that are
the same
each survey year so that we can do
we can have better understanding on the
time trend whether the behavior
is going up or going down or keep it the
same
and then for the questions or selection
process
we will take the cdc um questions as a
question based
and then consulted with each program
areas within public health with within
dhhs as well as with the department of
education
and i think there was a question about
how questions are selected we also
received
letters of support from the communities
to advocate a type of question or topic
to be included
in the yrbs and for that kind of
advocate questions we also take into
account uh in the question selection so
for doe department of education they
will have the final review of all the
questions that we're going to conduct in
thank you are there further questions
not seeing any thank you very much oh
yes go ahead
thank you um again abby rogers
legislative liaison i just wanted to
make a point of a technical point for
the committee uh the department was
asked to complete a fiscal note
worksheet on this bill i think it
originally was hp 1639 fn and we
contacted the lba because the fiscal
note worksheet we completed was not
attached to the bill and i was told that
the fn was removed um but we wanted to
just let you know that in our completion
of the fiscal analysis of the bill that
we would
need a data analyst position if the
survey were to become opt-in because of
the needed data we would have to do some
uh some some additional work around data
and also
that position would be
someone that would communicate and help
districts with
um questions related to the survey uh as
it would be an opt-in as opposed to an
an opt-out so there would be a one
full-time fte position that we would
need for that and i just wanted to share
that with the community uh did you do
any kind of a estimate as far as what
that would cost for that analysis a
hundred fifteen thousand dollars a year
i think it was about a hundred and
twelve thousand hundred and twelve yes i
just we just wanted to make you aware
further further questions
i'd like to invite holly stevens
sorry i'm not holly's yet to go to
another hearing you didn't look like
holly but that's fine
um
a lot of pink card if you want from me
um i'm ken norton okay ken i'll just
write your name on this one right then
representing naming new hampshire and
um
we are the national alliance on mental
illness and nonpartisan nonprofit
organization with a mission to improve
the lives of all people impacted by
mental illness and suicide in the
interest of time you've heard a lot of
testimony with a lot of people previous
speakers much more knowledgeable than
than i am i would just say specifically
for suicide and mental health that nami
new hampshire does use yrbs data
to identify
or hear from school districts sometimes
where yrbs data results are of concern
to them and they're looking to us to
help them
provide suicide prevention and training
we also use it for grant purposes and
it's very useful
we received a five-year
we're designated by the state to apply
for a five-year suicide use suicide
prevention grant and those
federal grants often
are looking to wire bs data from by
comparison to other states in order to
to identify and ensure that funds go to
states where the highest risk has been
identified
and we also oppose the the um
the the opt in measure for reasons that
have been previously stated
happy to answer any questions thank you
this we might first of all thank you for
taking the question and we might have
already covered this but uh i just i
wanted to be sure
so
the survey is redone every two years the
same group of students how often do they
take it are they taking it annually or
every two years or once in their high
school career
i believe it's every two years they take
it
so are we oh let me ask a follow-up go
ahead
are we measuring are we able to measure
how effective this survey is because i'm
hearing that the survey is valuable
because we're able to get resources out
there to these students so i'm just
wondering are we comparing let's say the
freshman class their survey results to
when they become juniors and have things
improved
i would defer to the public health folks
to answer that question but yes i think
some of what is available are trends and
comparisons
relative to the data that's been
identified
so there's solid metrics we can look at
yes
further questions
thank you very much thank you i'd like
new hampshire coalition against domestic
and
sexual violence
yes thank you good afternoon mr chair
and members of the committee my name is
pamela keilig and i am the public policy
specialist at the new hampshire
coalition against domestic and sexual
violence which is the umbrella
organization for our 12 community-based
crisis centers that provide free and
confidential services to about 15 000
survivors of domestic and sexual
violence each year
the coalition opposes hb
because of the limitations it would put
on
data collection for the youth risk
behavior survey
and i have with me today my colleague
joy smith who can speak and provide some
educational background on the
significance that this survey has to the
for the record my name is joy smith and
i am the program director at the
coalition and i provide technical
support to the prevention educators at
crisis centers serve
as critical lines of support and
resources in their communities so beyond
providing crisis intervention services
to victims of domestic and sexual
violence
they also work to support schools in
their communities through conducting
trainings to faculty and staff
helping to respond to title ix
complaints and child abuse referrals
and anti-bullying efforts through
primary prevention work
prevention educators provide free
prevention programming tailored to the
specific needs
of the youth and families in their
communities
these programs focus on increasing the
protective factors that prevent violence
and reducing the risk factors that may
increase the likelihood of violence
occurring
over the last three years prevention
educators have conducted over thousand
five hundred presentations to more than
thirty three thousand adults and forty
four thousand youth
those efforts would be significantly
hampered without the accurate data to
reflect the realities of the experience
of young greatest granite staters in the
community
over the last three years the crisis
center advocates have helped more than 4
500 children and youth victims of
domestic and sexual violence
a major component of developing
successful and effective evidence-based
interventions is utilizing the data and
information obtained through the youth
risk behavior survey which directly
informs the prevention programming at
schools coordinated by your local crisis
centers
it's through these surveys and data that
that provide
i'm sorry it's through these surveys
and the data that they provide that we
can better understand the prevalence of
sexual abuse and violence and how
programming can be tailored to the needs
of students in schools
without consistent data collection we
will be unable to gather accurate
demographic information that is used to
develop strategies to prevent abuse
and harm in our communities
this is especially imperative
when you consider the impact that the
pandemic has had on domestic violence
sexual assault and child abuse and the
ability of crisis centers to conduct
prevention programming
crisis center advocates continue to
report increased outreach from school
districts and administrators schools are
witnessing a significant increase in
bullying incidents severe mental health
issues
and title ix reports and in response to
that the schools have requested more
support from their local crisis centers
to help
intervene
yeah so just in conclusion before we
begin to consider scaling back our
efforts to administrate this survey
we really ask that we consider the full
impact that changes to the data
collected could have on this important
and critical work that we do to try to
prevent child abuse and support our
schools in responding
to these incidences and so thank you so
much and we'd be happy to answer any
questions
representative hopps
thank you mr chair and thank you for
your testimony today i was wondering if
you could explain to me
how you decide what communities to help
what is the metric you use
and what is the process
thank you for the question
um so essentially it's
it's not necessarily determining
who we should be providing support to
it's determining what kind of
programming we should be bringing into
the schools depending on what kind of
issues the
students are experiencing um obviously
it's it's also an opt-in for the schools
to be bringing in their prevent the
prevention coordinators from the crisis
centers but the programming that they
develop is based off of the results of
this data and what the demographics look
representative cordelli
thank you mr chairman thank you for
being here and for your work
since you develop programming for
schools
um
i'm not sure what level yrbs data
you are
using
to make those determinations
if it is
regional data as we've heard such as the
north country
that's a pretty big
uh chunk of the state and how
with
that
level of data
do you come up with
pro school specific
uh programs
thank you that's a great question so um
each of our crisis centers are based out
of all of the different counties
throughout the state
so
the the data that we are able to
have access to through the dhhs website
the doe websites
gives us county-wide data
so we're able to
glean from that information what is
needed county-wide and so each program
we have a couple programs that share
counties depending on the areas
um that they're able to use utilize that
data for those specific counties
which would be within their catchment
areas
further questions
do you feel it be advantageous to your
organization if you were to receive
data
regarding these counties for example i
live in a county where
grafton
where the population exists in hanover
lebanon plymouth
maybe if you consider littleton way up
north but that's really not that large
um
so i
my question then is would you
do you perceive that data that you're
getting back the same for the larger
urban oriented places as you do the
smaller communities
how you know how widespread are some of
these issues
etc so i would say that it would be it
would be more effective for our
prevention educators and our member
programs to have um
more specific data uh broken down by
town
or by by specific community because it
is a little challenging specifically for
grafton county we have three member
programs that serve grafton county and
so it is really challenging because you
have uh pockets of rural communities and
then you have uh you know
um communities that are a little you
know have larger populations and so the
needs are going to be different but
currently we're only able to access the
the data
thank you very much
further questions from the committee
nacional thank you very much for coming
today thank you
uh next person would be sarah scott
americans for prosperity new hampshire
that's okay they both have threes in it
okay uh and the last card i have that is
jamai wilder
yeah
uh good afternoon my name is jama wilder
and i live in hollis new hampshire
i came here today and
i wanted to support this bill because of
my personal experience at the high
school
when i first heard about the survey it
was when my daughter was calling me from
the high school so upset about what was
being asked her
she told me that it went through the
school like wildfire and
that it was all over social media and
that everyone in the school was talking
about how upset they were
my son
also took home or tried to take home the
survey to show me because he was so
disturbed about the questions
our school never gave us the option um
to opt out or let us know that they were
going to be giving the survey to the
students but they had been planning it
for over a month because i spoke with
another teacher and they redid their
whole calendar schedule so that there
was two teachers in each classroom
giving the survey
the teacher i spoke to said that she
felt so uncomfortable with it that she
didn't go to school that day
i'm not sure if any of you have read any
of the questions so i've picked and
highlighted a few that really concern me
the reason i'm reading them to you is
because
so far all i've heard for testimony
today is people talking about grants
looking for money to fund programs that
they want and i'm coming to you today to
say this is not good for our students
for the children
and
it's leaving them with a lot of
questions and no one to follow up with
it
there's a whole section that talks about
suicide
it says the next six questions ask about
feeling sad and attempted suicide
sometimes people feel so depressed about
the future that they may consider
attempting suicide that is taking some
action to end their own life
during the past 12 months did you ever
feel so sad or hopeless almost every day
for two weeks or more in a row that you
stopped you doing some usual activities
during the last 12 months did you ever
seriously consider attempting suicide
make a plan about how you would attempt
suicide during the last 12 months how
many times did you actually attempt
suicide
when you feel sad
empty hopeless angry or anxious how
often do you get the kind of help you
need
those questions alone for someone that's
struggling with depression and leaving
them with no one to follow up has now
planted seeds in their mind with no one
to talk to all they're going to do is
play those ideas over and over in their
head
this is like a playbook for how to do
bad things
i learned more about vaping
the
names of specific drugs every
street name that you could learn that
i've never even heard of before i read
this survey
if a child is struggling with
the idea of body image whether it's
anorexia bulimia
body dysphoria
they are reading the survey asking
questions
about
how do you describe your weight very
underweight slightly underweight about
the right weight slightly overweight
very overweight which are the of the
following are you trying to do about
your weight lose weight gain weight stay
the same weight i'm not trying to do
anything about my weight
they also ask questions
like this during your life with whom
have you had sexual content i've never
had sexual contact females males males
and females which of the best describes
you heterosexual straight gay or lesbian
bisexual i describe my sexual identity
some other way i'm not sure about my
sexual identity questioning i do not
it also for young boys that are curious
about sex
asks about pornography but it doesn't
just ask if they're looking at it it
tells them where they can look at it
have you ever seen pornography also
called porn either on purpose or by
accident count any porn that you saw
including pictures or on tv phones
computers or ipads or other tablets in
books magazines or movie theaters
i have heard a lot of testimony today
talking about how people are getting
good information from this
but my son went in and he said that he
was a 200 pound black male or black
female and said that most of the kids in
this class did the same thing
he said that
they made jokes of it and they didn't
take it seriously every testimony i've
heard has said that these children are
answering these questions correctly
when you're asking about child abuse or
if they've been sexually abused and
you're expecting someone to be honest
with you and not even being able to
connect
i feel like these things are completely
uh
ridiculous that you would believe that a
teenage child anywhere from the ages of
12 or 13 if they're starting in junior
high to 18 are going to be honest on a
a week after this survey was given a boy
in our
community committed suicide
i started to do some research and the
teen screen that was enacted after
george w bush was in office in 2003
started asking these kids questions
what they found through their research
is that
the anxiety and the depression and the
suicide rates were going up
i had to do training uh on suicide
awareness to volunteer in my school
and in that survey
or in in the um
in the education it it referenced the
cdc survey and that there was an
increase significantly
rate of suicides over the years it also
said since the surveys come out they saw
something they'd never seen before in
2017 to 18 in jordan district utah where
there were seven suicides they started
it not only talks about drinking drugs
vaping sex abuse how often body weight
and suicide
but this is damaging questions for our
children to be asked especially in light
of the pandemic
they don't know who to turn to
the schools have put them on lockdowns
and they don't have people to turn to
and by giving them information that they
don't know how to process you're hurting
them
and as a parent i should have had the
right to opt out but i didn't
instead
the school destroyed the surveys
and notified the parents that they had
made a mistake but they broke the law
and they never emailed the survey to
the parents so all of the other parents
that didn't do their due diligence to
look up this survey
now have no idea what their kids might
have been exposed to
so i'm asking you to think about the
students and what the parents think is
best for their children
because i i can guarantee you that
most parents would not feel comfortable
with someone a school administrator or
teacher asking them these questions and
not following it up
and there were some kids at this school
that actually put their name on the
survey
because they didn't realize that it
wasn't a test you have no control over
in bedford a father was very upset
and he went to the school and he told
them that he wanted them to find his
students survey and destroy it and the
school found it and destroyed it
you can't sit here everyone that just
testified and tell me they don't know
who these kids are because if they
answer the questions correctly
they know
the first several questions of the
survey
paint a clear picture
i think i read within three questions
they could determine the student
so i'm asking
that you pass this and protect the
parent parents rights
and protect our our children
and i would also
recommend that each one of you reads
through the 106 questions on the survey
and think about how you would feel if
that was given to your child
thank you
thank you very much are there is there
anybody from the committee would like to
ask a question
yes representative nelson thank you i'm
not sure this you could answer this but
you have any idea how special needs
students or administered that uh
somebody that difficulty reading with a
teacher ever read it read them the
questions or you have any idea my
understanding was is that they brought
two of the cav blocks together in hollis
and they had two teachers there and one
of them administered it if they had a
para i don't know because um
my i don't think that my children have
any special need children in their calf
blocks
um because i think that calf locks use
as a time where people can meet with um
other teachers for extra help
are there further questions from the
committee
not seeing hands thank you very much for
your testimony today thank you you're
welcome
do we have any more cards or is that it
is there anybody else out there with a
pink card not seeing any thank you very
holy
we're going to take a five minute break
so so folks can get up and stretch those
legs do a little physical exercise ben
stretch
that's going to be your response i agree
with you
i'll even help pay for it
get the coffee
we do have a machine that's correct i
it's one of them with little
i don't know i wouldn't trust the water
in the machine though it's probably over
a year old
that'll get you awake if it touches
anything
i know you're not supposed to drink
is that
everybody
most everybody
um
with that i think we will
open our final hearing of the day
which is house bill
1329 relative to alternative programs
for credit leading to high school
graduation
and our
first speaker is the sponsor
thank you very much representative
cordelli members of the
education committee for the record my
name is rick ladd i'm a representative
from haverhill new hampshire and i'm
here today to introduce 1329
the bill is relative to programs for
credit leading to high school graduation
and allows it to also be done beyond
where we do it now with the high schools
but would pursuant to the state board of
education adopting rules which will
enable that board to also recognize
that a course taken
is going to give you credit for
graduation
this bill as you see it right here
is the exact exact wording that was in
242 hb 242.
we've discussed it before many a time
so i'm not going to take the time to go
in it and over it and over and over
again i think it reads pretty simply
that the
the
if a student has taken a course in an
alternative learning program that credit
if not awarded by the high school itself
or the district
can be if it's in accordance with the
rules and if that program was accepted
and approved by the state board
and meets the competencies as
established
within the high school course
then they will get credit for that
course
i want to also make a note that you have
another bill in front of you today
not today but in your bills for this
month
hb 1661
that's a bill regional career technical
education agreements
now if you look at that bill you're also
going to see very similar wording in it
the uh career technical education
committee that we have studying tuition
and transportation
also the advisory council has looked at
that bill so i won't go into it because
we haven't introduced it yet but there's
language within it that reads
a student completing an embedded career
technical education course who
demonstrates proficiency in the embedded
course at competencies as approved by
the sending district board under terms
of the rctea agreement you'll get that
later or by the state board of education
shall have such credits counted toward
required program area for a high school
degree or diploma
we've had
direct communication
from
uh directors of the cte centers and
doesn't have to be a ct center we've
also had the communication from others
regarding transfer of credit to the
that's been previously uh obtained
elsewhere be it in a school which is an
approved school be it a school that's
accredited with the same association we
accredit our schools
but we know that
in regard to the cte program
which is very similar to this
concept and this whole idea of the state
board getting engaged
there are some sending districts
even though the competencies that are
taught in that chemistry class back in
the sending district
are taught in a part of the programming
at the cte center
the student must take
the required course at the sending
school
this has
resulted in
many students
that are going from sending schools to
career tech centers not able to go
seeing they have to stay back to take
that one course that they need for
graduation
rather than getting involved with a
skill oriented program at the cte
centers
this this particular concept has been
discussed over and over and over again
at various meetings we've had throughout
the
last spring summer fall
with directors with
cte people and they're all agreement
we've got to get on the same page here
and we need to get our 10th 11th and
12th
grade kids engaged
in learning at these centers we have far
too few kids in that pro in the program
right now compared to other states like
delaware where they have over 50 percent
of their high school students have taken
at least one cte program in our state
it's 17 percent same amount of kids in
delaware as there are here in new
hampshire we have a problem
the majority of kids taking courses at
the cte centers are 70 percent
in that school itself like a candidate
which has the cte right there in its
school which is a great program
or in any of the other schools which
where they're this they're embedded like
concord high
however if you look at those sending
districts that's where the percentages
start really
significantly dropping off in
participation transportation et cetera
and also someone being held back
uh by people are saying no you will take
it in my course at the ascending school
you will not get it embedded in so
that's the same concern that we have
within the bill we're talking about
right here
that there is a need due especially
during this period of covid
where we're having to look at so many
different options now where we've had
schools legitimately not in session at
the school we've had to zoom we've had
to do this or that and and i understand
all that however we are seeing
significant drops in the achievement of
kids
we've seen it it's documented in
mathematics we've gone from the
48th percentile level of proficiency
level to 38 proficiency in public
education in mathematics we have long
ways to go that's we're going to have to
start relying upon these other options
as well as offering to tutorial services
remediation in our public schools help
kids out we need to have this
alternative program of learning these
programs are approved by the department
and
therefore they do meet the competencies
so in conclusion i would like to see
this bill go forward thank you
uh thank you representative
representative porter
thank you mr chair um for letting me ask
my question and thank you representative
i was not part of all those other
conversations as i'm new on the
committee
and as i'm understanding this bill not
the one about the ctes
that
the state department of education can
override
the local school board that the decision
of what counts for graduation
in a local district is no longer
the record is no longer what the school
board says it is the school board has
now given that over to the local to the
state board of education
the state board is not can i can can i i
want to tell you a story that happened
in hillsboro just a brief story a young
girl
decided she didn't want to go to
hillsboro anymore got involved in a
program in concord she was a senior
she finished up the year
in the concord program
and wanted to come back and graduate in
hillsborough with her
her old grade mates
and there was a big concern at that time
and a lot of public
unhappiness
because the public
said she had not met the requirements
that hillsborough had for its students
to graduate she had met requirements
from a different place and therefore she
had not res she was not eligible to
receive a diploma from hillsboro during
high school so that's an actual thing
that happened in my community a few
years ago
and i'm seeing with this something
similar
all of a sudden the state board is
saying that sally jones can take this
in
another town
and come back and still graduate
with her class even though it doesn't
meet the requirements that hillsboro has
set
so that's why i'm concerned about this
bill and that's why i asked the question
the question should be answered has
sally jones master the competencies
relative to that particular course that
she's not getting credit for or having
to take again
we have forgotten that when we made a
move to go forward when commissioner
barry was here
the idea of instruction is based upon
competencies it's not seat time it's not
where you're taking this class or
program it's what you have gained or
learned it's whether you have attained
that learning target if you've attained
that learning target if you can
demonstrate that you have those
competencies then i would say the
student absolutely deserves to have that
counsel account course that course count
towards
graduation and move on
rather than getting taught in this old
regiment that we have you're going to
have to do everything
lock stock barrel in this school
and and step with every other student
that's not the way how life is and it
thank you representative taner
thank you mr chair and thank you for
i recently asked uh attorney fenton uh
and i think she's in the process of
doing that sending me the the rules from
the department of education
um about how
how they vet
how they
get the valid completion certificate
from the state board of education for
alternative programs
and i'm wondering how
they determine the state board of
education which i may find out but maybe
you know how they decide
whether it's a quarter credit half
credit
full credit two credits
i recently talked to a superintendent in
my area just to give you a little
anecdotal thing and somebody showed up
at the high school door
a parent with their child
who said that their child belong in in
uh the junior year of school and
they asked for
you know some sort of transcript where's
the transcript where's
some level of
what this child had completed and the
parent merely turned over
a sheet handwritten sheet of paper and
said they've done math they've done
english they've done whatever
and you have to accept this and um
you know i think there's two sides of
the story i really i thoroughly agree
that
people need to be outside the school
system uh doors outside the school doors
taking classes having experiences
getting credit for it
um and getting that through competencies
and i think the schools
normally write up the competencies that
the
that the students pass or
achieve and get a certain amount of
credit for it i'm just wondering how how
credit is determined
uh at the state level for
you know
what they're completing
for example can a kid
get a job at hannaford's be a checkout
clerk
you know learn how to do money maybe
learn how to do stocking
shelves and stuff like that and get a
basic math credit for it
well that's why we have uh education 306
it's
standards for public school approval uh
minimum standards for public school
approval and within that if we you look
at the book you're going to see that how
many credits are awarded for various
types of courses that's all within 306.
that's that's not in
this book that we have right
no you're looking at the statutes uh
three zero six are rules okay
and so then you better get your rules
out and if you don't have copies we need
to be asking the department to get us
copies because the my last set of rules
were based luckily right around 2015 16
somewhere here
um
probably 2014-15
and uh but i
i think that we're in a moment in our in
our
experience of education here a time
when we we have to
um
get rid of the walls
um it's also i have a meeting coming up
in two days of plymouth state university
working with president
don burks
and he's now stated if you come out of
that school with an associate degree
and you go to plymouth state
out of white mountain community college
and you go to plymouth state you will
come in as a junior
that's very important now it's not going
to be questioning what you had
previously it's automatically going to
be approved you are a junior i think
that when we come in from another place
where you're either having coming from a
school
that's uh accredited through the new
england association
um or netchie and and you uh
or you're
and definitely you're coming from an
approved program of our states that our
state board has approved that's the key
right there
then
then the credits awarded would be in
conjunction with 306 and working with
that district and finding okay are you
giving a half credit for this a full
credit quarter credit as you've
mentioned that that has to be discerned
and it should be understood
what they receive
in that school district should be what
they receive elsewhere for it i believe
but i'm not the person making that
decision
i'm just echoing what i understand to be
in rule right now and done by the board
state board
hopefully i'll get the rules
uh thank you um the rules are all on the
d.o.e website also
um
representative ellison
thank you mr chairman thank you thank
you for taking my question i should know
the answer to this
uh but
what is your take on the process
that the department now uses
to approve alternative programs is there
is that laid out in the rules at this
point i mean can we
figure that one out as to
you do this you apply you you know
there's a group that passes judgment on
these programs and says yes to this one
yes to this one no to that one or
well represent ellison
i don't think i'm the person to give you
the answer in that i think you're going
to have to that's a good question
i'm not familiar with process that they
go through with uh
it might be something to be asking
directly of the department through the
folks that are here maybe or it's true
directly to
drew klein who chairs the state board
okay
thank you you're welcome uh if
if i could just interject i i've talked
for several years about the civil air
patrol as being a prime candidate for
learn everywhere
and unfortunately i was not able to move
that forward i turned it over to the
cadet of the excuse me the major in
charge of the legislative squadron who
is moving that forward and i sent to him
the there's a complicated application um
you have to supply uh the curriculum
basically that's involved and so they
are now moving forward with having civil
air patrol uh programs um accredited
through the learn everywhere process uh
for
um
uh civil air patrol cadets uh to gain
credits
could i ask could i ask you a question
well sure i i i i i i can't see
no no i'm sorry this is relates to
representatives cordelia's uh point i
i'm assuming there's a process then
there's a format they fill it out i'm
assuming there's a list of approved
programs somewhere that the department
published either
the air cadets are on it or they're not
but that there's a list of approved
alternative programs but that may be
assumption another assumption i'm making
that's not true
i i believe there is a list on the
um for any further questions for the
organizations which deal with concurrent
dual enrollment we dealt with that and
would there are certain standards which
but i'm unfamiliar with what you're
speaking of i
i've had classes in spanish and latin
vietnamese i wish there was something
that you're suggesting because i can't
speak a word in any of them
um
so it was actually you know something
which was really not benefiting me well
vietnamese did i i still have a lot of
excuse me representative
if i could um ask you to turn your mic
on thank you thank you i
keep forgetting that thing
um
it is a process that many universities
use it allows them not to have to offer
courses in say swahili which they would
have a limited enrollment in and
wouldn't be viable economically but the
person can then establish their through
their their competence in the language
and level of confidence and therefore
they can be awarded credit and these are
it's a very
valid process
the only thing i i've touched with that
as as a father when my
daughter who's now the speech therapist
audiologist was in high school and the
literature that she needed wasn't being
taught there in alaska and she took us
course through the university of kansas
for high school kids which was
immediately accepted
but that's a little bit different what
you're talking about it's it's different
but it's still competency-based yes it
was when the assessment is made it's
made on the basis of competence and it
was also
when she was admitted into elmira
uh she was given a competency test to
find out where she would be placed
within that program and she did quite
well with that so
um competency's been around a long time
and that's the way we should be
measuring
uh the competencies uh whether they get
uh credit for a course or not
thank you you're welcome any
yes representative cornell
thank you and thank you for taking my
question i totally agree with you about
the cte competencies i'm on that
cte advisory council and manchester
school of technology is all competency
based so
it works but
what last year when we were discussing
high schools not accepting velax
i called velex and they said the only
time they ever had a problem was when
the parent or
what student wanted the high school to
accept
an outside course
for a required course and it was an
elective
so
you're saying maybe granted for
coursework michelle accept credits for
high school graduation
but what if they're wanting it to go
toward
a requirement for graduation but the
class the outside coursework really
wasn't
thank you very much uh representative
cornell you've hit why we are
putting the language in the cte
because it's usually in your freshman
year
sophomore year you're still taking some
of those required courses
and those
course that type of uh course
is preventing
a student because now we lower the level
for gray for our ctes to 10th grade
from going in their 10th grade and
getting involved with the program that
they really should be there and they
could get the competency for that
requirement so the
in in that case the course the
competencies acquired at the ct
will not come back and count as an
elective they will count as that
required course that they
were able to take over there this is the
way i see this program as well
but i i'm i'm not concerned about the
ctes because i know that they're being
done in school but i'm saying an outside
learn everywhere course
that's been approved that could be
skiing that they want to bring back to
the school and have it count as their
science class because they were outside
and getting that that would not occur in
this program right because there's
you can't just go off and take a course
in something just to have a course it's
not like recertification where you take
your up to your five or six credits
whatever you have to and it can be
anything in your field that's a wide
open game this is not wide open if you
look at education 306 it's going to
specifically state
the subject area the subject learning
domains that these uh credits are
offered in
course taken
yes
the local school district can say no
then to that
if they i would imagine they could say
no if they're if
if the student through the state board
is trying to carry in a course which is
on basket weaving and they need this in
literature okay thank you you're welcome
any further
yes i guess there are representative
mullen thank you mr chair and thank you
for taking my question
you referenced representative uh the
example of a student taking a college
class at the university of kansas or
whatever and
transferring it in
generally speaking in college situations
there's a limit to the amount of credits
that one
university will allow transferred in
from another university
um is there anything in this bill that
would
somehow temper whether or not somebody
took
every course but one
in an alternative program and then
came in and wanted it applied towards a
local high school diploma i don't think
there's anything to temper that uh i i
can't imagine somebody doing it but
that's possible uh and by the way the
the course which we took at the
university of kansas it was not a
college they had a correspondent school
attached to the university so they were
offering high school level courses
through that university in kansas
uh that was done in alaska often times
seeing that you're often in a small
community where you didn't have these
offerings and so they went on the
correspondence type study and that's how
they they did it there those are
automatically accepted could i have a
follow-up representative you may thank
you um
so here's here's my question i
personally as a representative
have had feedback from local folk
who are not happy with what they're
describing as local control which is a
big deal in the state of new hampshire
as you well know
being taken away
with regards to
our high school and school board working
to determine blah blah blah how you know
what should be part of the diploma
situation
so my question to you is do you not get
any of that feedback and if you do how
do
i how do you manage it represent mullen
i've not had that feedback i the the
folks i've talked to primarily are ones
where the
the the student has
come in from another location
the school would not accept that course
and they're out of step out of sync with
the rest of students at that grade level
they're in and they took this course and
it counted towards the credit that they
evidently were not giving
credit for um
i i i'm not familiar with where i'm not
getting that type of feedback from
community where i am
uh representative tanner i know i well i
draw the line right across the state
so
two states in this state i'm west of
concord okay
um
just following up on what representative
ford said about people uh you know
having the ability to do something like
like speak swahili or they're coming
from another another place
and they have the competency but the
local
university or local school that accepts
that person
actually tests them to see what grade
they belong in or or ask them to
show their competency so that they can
uh meet the standards of that particular
school i'm just
you know that's that's kind of where i'm
coming from that
that uh
and i'm i'm not sure do you think that
that that happens that the if the state
of new hampshire the department of
education says
you know uh johnny jones completed this
course
uh give him one credit in english and um
the local school district says
you know this is what we do in
that particular english class these are
the competencies that we've set up for
uh that required course
um are you willing to demonstrate that
competency here we'll give you credit
for it i i just can respond to that i
think that there should be communication
between the department that does that
and and the school district they can
discuss this there might be some other
issues that are not being coming to the
surface
that's why
in the other program i spoke to we call
it the rctea there are regional
agreements
and the agreements are between the
sending and receiving schools some of
those schools you know we have nine or
so
sending schools to one center and that
creates some real huge problems in terms
of scheduling for kids as well as
getting the required courses necessary
for graduation
and we're learning that we have to
communicate and work together on so many
issues and aligning our curriculum and i
realized that with a career in technical
education and i i totally agree that the
you know i know that the schools are
working together just like um
representative cornell said what i'm
concerned about is the alternative
credits where
uh someone decides that
like i said they're going to mow the
lawn for grandma for a month and that
should be their pe credit
um
and they bring it to the school and the
school says well you know this this is
our requirement maybe it's maybe it's a
fitness course or something that they
have to do
and um should the high school have that
resp that ability in order to give them
graduation credits or determine what
level they're in whether they're in
grade 10 or 11 english
should they have that ability to to ask
the person to the student to show
competency
to them i think that would be something
that the department would have to find
out
and determine that
we have academic standards which are set
by the state
then we have competencies which are
relative to what's going on in your
curriculum in your district there has to
be some kind of a relationship there or
else competencies to measure
those academic standards which we're
leaping towards and so
this will work
we got to communicate and talk with each
other
and and offer students this opportunity
to move forward
uh in a way that
not just always best fits them but
uh
helps them with their scheduling and
achieving that goal as quickly as
possible so they can move on in higher
education
thank you any further questions for yes
uh representative
uh president ford if you could first
press the button and turn on your mic
right exactly thank you you've got the
routine now
yeah don't be so sure you may have to
representative ladd i'm wondering if
you're familiar with the practice of
many universities when presented with
courses for transfer
and it's in the field we'll just say
english because that's my field and the
course doesn't exactly match to the
address my colleagues concerned uh just
asked
and but it meets the criteria for
transfer so that the university can opt
to give them credit in that discipline
but not necessarily in fulfillment of
that requirement
and that some
not uncommonly happens particularly if
there's several courses involved or
different things you may satisfy some
companies and not i just wondered
whether you were familiar with that well
i can remember as a young officer in the
service how we had we worked with the
maryland university
they were one of the first ones to start
going in this direction
and there are articulation agreements
too between the military and in that
university so that uh
we could get credit for you know all
that pt physical
work we're going through and running
around the track and all this other
and um i think that proved to be very
beneficial and helpful
that those agreements were in place
and um
it saved a great deal of money for
myself but i think they work
i agree they did i yeah but participated
in some of that yeah though articulation
agreements between the levels is very
important
thank you
um
representative ford you've got half the
process down
okay
any further questions from the committee
uh seeing none thank you uh thank you
next is
all right thank you mr chairman and
members of the committee for the
opportunity to testify here today
my name is sarah scott and i'm the
director of grassroots operations with
americans for prosperity new hampshire
and on behalf of afp new hampshire and
our activists all across the state we
urge you to support house bill 1329
which would solidify alternative
learning programs and specifically the
learn everywhere program into statute
so back in 2018
the legislature passed legislation
enabling the learn everywhere program
which gives students credit for the
learning that's already taking place
outside of the classroom
and this legislation allowed the new
hampshire department of education to
then go and develop a program that has
really been at the forefront of
innovation among other states
so since the launch of the learn
everywhere program back at the end of
we've had at least a dozen programs that
have been approved for credit
and this has given thousands of new
hampshire students access to high school
credit for the learning that they're
already participating in so this
includes organizations such as first
robotics
the seacoast science center and the boys
and girls club of souhegan valley so
students participating in these programs
will now have time to explore new
subject areas or get extra help where
they might be struggling
so this legislation would solidify
programs like learn everywhere and
ensure that these students continue to
receive credit for the learning that's
already taking place so it's for these
reasons that we ask that you recommend
this legislation as ought to pass and
continue to allow new hampshire high
school students to earn credit for the
learning that takes place both in and
outside of the classroom
so i wanted to kind of cover a couple of
the questions that representatives asked
earlier
so i'm forgetting a lot of them but i
know representative tanner asked one
about
credits
and i wanted to speak specifically about
the learn everywhere program how credits
are determined there
so if a program would like to be
approved by
as a learn everywhere provider they go
through and submit an application to the
state board of education
and part of that application process
includes competencies and right now
the local public schools determine
credits based on competencies and the
learner everywhere programs do the same
so if a course
was submitted an application that had
two competencies for example it wouldn't
count as a full year of learning because
that's not what's counted at a local
public school
so
they line up the competencies number of
competencies based on the credit hours
for that
and these are things that go through a
process of
not just laying out the
competencies but explaining how their
programs match up to that and then going
through and seeing asking how you
evaluate students progress on it and
then how you determine when mastery is
met so these programs go through a
pretty substantial application process
they're reviewed by the department and
then
teachers as well and then they go before
the state board of education
i know there were other questions but i
couldn't remember them so i'm happy to
take any other questions
thank you
representative porter
at any point in that process
do local school boards get to approve
these programs
so i would say this is about the same as
if a student took a vlax course
so right now students that take velox
courses go in and they're approved at
the local public school
this is the same exact process
the majority of learn everywhere
programs actually base their
competencies off of the um vlax
competencies so they're already approved
um and it's the same coursework then
going into the local schools
follow-up yeah who approved the v-x
i believe it's approved at the state
level but it's something that's
currently accepted and widely accepted
throughout the public schools here do
all public schools accept it yes thank
you
thank you any further
uh questions um actually i have one
maybe if i could
jump in
since afp is a national organization do
you have any idea is
this learn everywhere program unique to
new hampshire
thank you for the question um so new
hampshire was the first state to come up
with the learn everywhere program but
since then it's been passed in a number
of different states
i know it's in probably at least three
or four right now and other
states are looking to pass the same
legislation this year largely brought on
by um the pandemic and they've found
that kids that were staying home over
the course of the last year have found a
number of different alternative programs
that they've been participating in and
so now they're trying to go back and
figure out how kids can get credit for
that um in these states and what they've
kind of looked forward to model based
off of this is the learn everywhere
program
thank you uh representative mullen
we have a good memory mr chair thank you
thank you thank you for taking my
question ms scott um back
to your comments about not offering full
credit if something
met two competencies but that didn't
seem to equate to a full semester of
study or whatever
is that
how places like the boys and girls club
or whatever
qualify as learn everywhere programs
would they
award
a competency in let's say
physical fitness or pe or whatever but
not in a subject matter
uh thank you for the question so
essentially how it works now is programs
apply to the program not just as a
provider but they apply for a specific
program so the boys and girls clubs
specifically applied for a theater
credit
so they went through and found the
competencies that would they looked at
velox and other public schools and what
they would have gone through for
competencies and then
essentially
picked which ones they followed and said
this is how we can explain it and then
they matched up what their program does
and how it aligns to those competencies
representative tanner
thank you mr chair um i'm just wondering
um
what what is the involvement in the
americans for prosperity with the
alternate with uh learn everywhere
program
uh thank you for the question so we're
just advocating that
people are able to participate in it
this is one of many programs that we
kind of would say educate people on
we've also done it on any number of
other learning options whether it be
charter schools public schools home
schools micro schools anything like that
that gives kids more options
always something that we're going out
and talking to parents about
and i have also spoken with a number of
different organizations about applying
for it
pretty much all of the
currently approved programs are things
that various people have suggested and
brought in so one of the programs that
was approved was a karate school i've
done karate for a number of years and i
ran a school by myself so i thought this
was a really good program for those
schools to get in so it's kind of just
like that where
people from across the state have
suggested various programs and
encouraged them to apply
you may
uh thank you as if as a follow-up is
there any financial involvement other
than perhaps hiring you as a lobbyist is
that is that the only financial
involvement you have with the learn
everywhere program uh yes thank you
any further questions for ms scott
see none thank you very much
and i believe that that is the last
person to testify on this bill
and for the day
so i will close the hearing
on
house bill 1329
and uh thank everyone for the long day
and
you